et la parole est à Monsieur rofrichter
rapporteur de la commission des finances
pour 7 minutes
la commission des finances monsieur
rapporteur général chers collègues
l'examen de la mission outre-mer et
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
situation des outre-mer et de manière
récurrente et récursive d'encourager le
gouvernement à intensifier les efforts
budgétaires en faveur du rattrapage des
écarts forts et persistants qui
demeurent entre les territoires
d'outre-mer et la France métropolitaine
dans les domaines sociaux économiques il
faut saluer l'effort budgétaires un
nouveau consacré par le gouvernement la
République en dépit de la
sous-consommation chronique de certaines
lignes de crédit consacrée à nos
collectivités ultramarines
si la progression des crédits du
programme 138 reste relative et tente à
être neutralisée par l'inflation cette
hausse est incontestable sur le
programme 123 du fait du développement
de dispositif de soutien exceptionnel
aux collectivité avec une augmentation
de 7,19% en AE et de 6,25% CP soit 43,4
millions d'euros
ces défenses sont importants mais la
tâche reste immense au lendemain de la
crise sanitaire et en toucher
brutalement les économies de nos
territoires éloignés globalement une
manière plus marquée dans certains
territoires les écarts avec la métropole
ont eu tendance à s'accroître en dépit
des efforts de tous pour juguler la
crise ainsi le PIB par habitant
enregistre en moyenne une légère
diminuation diminution d'outre-mer entre
2019 et 2021 alors qu'il enregistre une
hausse de plus de 5% en métropole en
Guadeloupe Nouvelle-Calédonie Polynésie
le PIB par habitant a diminué entre 2019
et 2021 dans les autres territoires
d'outre-mer il enregistre une
progression comprise entre 1,93% et 3 78
contre 5 22 en hausse en métropole
les évolutions démographiques sont
contrastées sur les différents bassins
océaniques mais introduisent des besoins
nouveaux pour faire face au profil de la
pyramide des âges tantôt jeunes et
croissante pour la Guyane Mayotte la
Nouvelle-Calédonie la Polynésie
française tantôt en baisse et
vieillissante notamment dans les
Antilles ce plan des infrastructures
publiques l'équipement de nos
territoires d'outre-mer restent
aujourd'hui souvent insuffisante pour
répondre à l'ensemble des besoins de la
population
défaillant sur un certain nombre d'entre
eux ou présentant des coûts pour
l'usager d'un supérieur à ce constater
en métropole malgré le déploiement
d'outils d'aide à l'investissement
depuis de nombreuses années déploiement
qu'il nous faut objectivement saluer
nous pouvons sur ce plan noter en
matière de santé que le PLF prévoit
l'inscription en 4 millions d'euros en a
eux et en CP pour la Polynésie française
afin d'améliorer la prise en charge des
patients favorisant l'accès la qualité
des soins en population des îles
éloignées avec l'acquisition de nouveaux
équipements pour les 102 soins et le
développement de la télémédecine mais
aussi par le soutien de la filière
oncologie pour le traitement du cancer
à cette situation difficile ce plan des
équipements s'ajoutent des variations
également contrastées face au fléau
mondial que constitue aujourd'hui
l'inflation la Guyane et la Polynésie
française étant plus durement touchée
qu'en métropole les habitants nos
collectivités ultramarines sont donc
bien affectés par l'inflation qui
enregistre une hausse notable malgré
l'existence du bouclier qualité prix mis
en place en 2012 en cette inflation
s'ajoute à un coût de la vie déjà
structurellement supérieur dans les
territoires d'outre-mer renchérissant
encore l'approvisionnement des ménages
des entreprises et des collectivités
ultramarines si des initiatives ont pu
annoncées aux banc de l'Assemblée
nationale par le gouvernement nous
restons attentifs à toute initiative
visant à limiter l'inflation en
outre-mer et à protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des citoyens français
ultramarins en particulier sur plan des
produits alimentaires
il résulte de ce contexte économique que
la situation financière des
collectivités d'outre-mer se détériorent
et certains d'entre elles ne peuvent
plus faire face aux investissements
pourtant si nécessaire cette dégradation
structurelle de la situation financière
explique d'ailleurs en partie les
problèmes de sous-consommation
régulièrement constatées sur la mission
un soutien des collectivités
ultramarines reste indispensable et doit
être renforcé dans cette période de
crise économique face aux écarts de
développement et à une pauvreté qui
peine à ce trésorber le contexte de
tension sociale a conduit à faire
entendre plus fortement la voie des élus
des Outre-mer en mai 2022 si cet appel
au changement des politiques d'aide au
développement dans les territoires
d'outre-mer a été entendus la réponse
attendue ne saurait se limiter à sa
seule dimension financière sur ce plan
particulier cet effort doit néanmoins
passer par les crédits de la mission
c'est le cas évidemment mais également
par les crédits des autres missions du
budget de l'État et par les dépenses
fiscales
les dépenses fiscales rattaché à la
mission enregistre en 2023 une nouvelle
hausse en passant de 6 milliards 916
millions à 7 milliards 90 millions
d'euros nous saluons d'ailleurs la
prolongation nombreux dispositifs
fiscaux qui devaient s'éteindre en 2025
jusqu'en 2029 le Sénat y a contribué en
incluant les comme qui n'avaient pas été
intégrés à cette vague de prolongation
il faut s'en féliciter et rappeler que
cette mesure donnera de la visibilité
aux différents acteurs économiques
d'outre-mer nous avons cependant
cependant conscience des critiques
récurrentes qui sont faites sur ces
dépenses fiscales mais nous soulignons
des évaluations récemment été menées et
que d'autres sont prévus pour 2023 c'est
d'évaluations de même un exercice
complexe à la fiabilité relative mais
elle représente un préalable nécessaire
à une réflexion plus large sur les
dépenses fiscales et un maintien
légitimé des dispositifs de
défiscalisation de surcroît en
complément des dépenses fiscales les
territoires d'outre-mer bénéficient de
crédit en provenance d'autres programmes
du budget général qui sont retracés dans
le document de politique transversale
outre-mer
ces crédit en provenance de 101
programmes budgétaire relevant 32
missions dans 48 programmes en matière
d'emploi d'égalité des chances de
conditions de vie d'aménagement durable
de dotation collectivités territoriales
et de relance économique il permet aussi
de financer 5 plantes thématiques
outre-mer les plans d'action pour les
services d'eau potable avec le plan au
Dôme le Plan Séisme anti le plan sargass
2 le plan logement outre-mer le plan
chlordécone enfin parmi ces
contributions figures plus
particulièrement le crédit les crédits
du plan de relance nous notons conjoint
2022 1,4 milliards d'euros a été ouvert
en AE pour l'outre-mer dans le cas du
plan de relance à la même date 38,6% des
AE et 10,1% des CP ont été consommés
ils doivent nous conduire à être
vigilant à l'avenir notamment pour
éviter des redéploiements en cas
d'absence de consommation toutefois les
crédits du plan de relance se sont
accompagnés d'un effet de levier
important sur le financement des
collectivités et ont permis de financer
des projets indispensables au territoire
d'outre-mer et de renforcer les
dispositifs existants comme les contrats
de convergence ou la ligne budgétaire
unique à cet égard il est important de
souligner que lorsqu'ils ont été
orientés sur les dispositifs existants
les crédits ont été intégralement
consommés
ah si le montant total des contributions
budgétaires s'élèvera en 2023 à 20
milliards d'euros en à eux et après de
22 milliards d'euros en CP depuis 2018
l'effort total de l'État en faveur des
Outre-mer a augmenté de 3,6 milliards en
a eux et 5,4 milliards en CP cet effort
est remarquable et doit être encouragé
pour les exercices à venir je vous
propose de voter en faveur des crédits
la mission outre-mer merci de votre
attention
monsieur le rapporteur spécial la
commission des finances monsieur patient
vous avez la parole
la présidente monsieur le ministre cher
collègue
la mission outre-mer a pour principale
objectif le rattrapage des écarts
persistants entre l'outre-mer et la
métropole et la convergence des niveaux
de vie dans le domaine social économique
ces crédits sont essentiels pour les
territoires
ultramarins en ce qu'il représente des
aides exceptionnels ou complémentaires
aux dotations de fonctionnement et
d'investissement classique à louer à
l'ensemble des collectivités
un périmètre constant les crédits de la
mission même corrigés de l'inflation
enregistre une hausse de
187,6 millions d'euros en AE et de
181,6 millions d'euros en CP nous
saluons cet effort
notant que quelques mesures nouvelles
pour remontant total de 35 millions
d'euros en a eu et 23 millions d'euros
en CP sont intégrés dans la mission
outre-mer en PLF 2023
ce nouveau crédit permettront notamment
de financer le renforcement de
l'assistance technique auprès des
collectivités
le développement de l'alimentation en
eau potable en Guadeloupe le soutien au
dispositif de lutte contre le changement
climatique dans le Pacifique les efforts
pour la diversification agricole et
enfin la réforme de la fonction publique
territoriale à Wallis et Futuna
si on peut se régir de ces augmentations
de crédit d'autres points sont plus
préoccupants et méritent d'être souligné
les crédits ouverts au titre de la ligne
budgétaire unique la Elbi ne permet pas
de répondre aux besoins dans ce domaine
notamment concernant la résorption de
l'habitat insalubre c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons un amendement visant à
augmenter de 4 millions d'euros les
crédits alloués à cette réception
cette ouverture se justifie d'autant
plus que les crédits ouverts les
dernières années ont été intégralement
consommés
de surcroît les crédits à louer au
contrat de redressement outremer fameux
Corum reste stable dans le PLF initial
ils ont été augmentés de 30 millions
d'euros à l'Assemblée nationale
cependant dans ce contexte économique
qui accentue la dégradation de la
situation financière des collectivités
d'outre-mer nous estimons que ce
dispositif doit être renforcé pour
s'étendre un homme plus important de
collectivité
or les ouvertures de crédit adoptées à
l'Assemblée et retenue dans le texte du
Gouvernement alloué au Corum serait
destiné à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
au syndicat de l'autre Guadeloupe il
nous paraît donc indispensable d'ouvrir
20 millions d'euros pour les corums
c'est le sens de l'amendement de la
commission
enfin la consommation des contrats de
transformation et de convergence
continue d'interroger gageons que leur
prolongation d'une année permettra
d'engager le plus de crédit possible
concernant le programme 138 emplois
outremer les crédits enregistres en 2023
une baisse apparente de 15,6 millions
d'euros en a eux et de 11,2 millions
d'euros en CP en raison d'une mesure de
périmètre
toutefois les crédits alloués aux
exonérations de charge enregistre un
périmètre constant une hausse de plus de
200 2,7 millions d'euros
dans un contexte économique incertain il
est délicat ce stade d'avoir une
prévision fine de ce que pourrait être
le besoin réel en 2023 en raison des
éventuels conséquences sur l'emploi et
les salaires de l'inflation nous nous
montrerons donc attentif en cours
d'année au niveau de consommation de ces
crédits
par ailleurs les crédits loués au
Service Militaire Adapté enregistre une
ou deux une hausse de 45 millions
d'euros on a eu et 50 millions d'euros
en CP par adore par rapport à 2022 qui
s'explique par la création de deux
nouvelles compagnies en Polynésie à
Mayotte et par le déploiement à tous les
territoires du SMA 2025 plus qui a
notamment pour objectif d'ouvrir le
dispositif à de nouveaux publics
ce dispositif a démontré son efficacité
et son extension à des mineurs et à des
mères célibataires permettra sans aucun
doute une meilleure professionnalisation
et une meilleure intégration de ces
personnes
nous devons toutefois être vigilants sur
les taux d'insertion des prochaines
années dans un contexte économique
difficile
enfin les crédits au financement de
l'économie c'est-à-dire les microcrédits
l'aide au frais le prêt de développement
outre-mer son stables à 24 millions
d'euros cette stabilité bien que louable
pourrait cependant s'avérer insuffisant
pour couvrir les besoins réels en 2023
en effet dans le contexte économique
actuel la situation des entreprises en
2023 pourraient se détériorer et le
recours au micro crédit ou auprès
développement Thomer pourrait alors
enregistrer une hausse par rapport à
l'année 2021 voire 2022 or pour rappel
en 2020 année de Christ sanitaire ces
crédits avaient été sur exécutés à
hauteur de 8 millions d'euros afin
d'anticiper ce besoin nous vous
proposons un amendement pour ouvrir 5
millions d'euros supplémentaires
les crédits à louer à l'Outre-mer
augmente et dans ce contexte de crise
économique en raison de l'inflation cet
effort doit être salué il reste
toutefois beaucoup à faire et nous
devons œuvrer de concerts pour une
consommation accrue de ces crédit je
pense sincèrement que les couronnes sont
une des solutions pour améliorer la
situation financière des collectivités
leur capacité à investir et de fait la
consommation des crédits de la mission
malgré les réserves évoquées ne vous
proposerons donc de voter les crédits de
la mission outre-mer
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant madame michigeac rapporteur
pas envie de la commission des Affaires
économique
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques a
choisi de rendre en avis favorable sur
les crédits de la mission outre-mer pour
2023 nanson ni recommandation dans son
réserve car après analyse les
augmentations de crédit sont trop
souvent modestes ne couvrons pas même
l'inflation prévue pour 2023 je pense
notamment au crédit de la LBU ou ce
dédié à la continuité territoriale
cependant nous considérons ce budget
comme un budget de transition vers la
méthode renouvelée que vous monsieur le
ministre appelé de vos vœux ma première
observation porte sur le logement le
constat demeure inchangé d'année en
année celui de mon cruel de construction
comme de rénovation pour l'année 2021 ce
sont 303 6 logements locatifs sociaux et
très sociaux qui ont été livrés alors
que le besoin annuel est estimé à plus
de 8000 de même 1628 réhabilitations de
logements sociaux ont été menée à leur
terme en dépit des financements
importants du plan de relance concernant
la lutte contre l'habitative les crédits
2022 sont reconduits à leur même que les
besoins sentiments c'est pour cela que
je propose au nom de notre commission et
on concertation avec les rapporteurs
spéciaux un amendement visant à porter
les crédits à la hauteur des enjeux qui
s'attachent à la lutte contre l'inviter
indigne je souhaite également souligner
dans la continuité des travaux menés par
la délégation outre-mer la nécessité
d'organiser des Assises de la
construction en préalable à
l'établissement d'un troisième plan
logement ma seconde observation se porte
sur la formation au sens large je tiens
souligner la nouvelle montée en
puissance du service militaire adapté
qui sans être la seule réponse aux mots
de notre jeunesse reste un puissant
outils d'insertion socio-économique il
permet à travers la rigueur de
l'encadrement l'écoute et les proposée
de donner à nos jeunes en difficulté une
réelle chance je voudrais également ici
mettre en exergue nos jeunes diplômés du
baccalauréat ou sortant de prépa en
effet je m'étonne toujours que les
territoires ultramarins forts de leur
2,8 millions d'habitants ne disposent
d'aucune école de commerce d'ingénieurs
ou encore d'EP pourquoi les genoux
ultramarins devraient-ils toujours aller
étudier en hexagone il serait temps
d'ouvrir une réflexion par bassin
géographique sur l'offre de
l'enseignement supérieur présent en
outre-mer et si les mots que les jeunes
souhaitant venir étudier à Paris puisse
le faire dans de bonnes conditions
pourquoi ne pas imaginer demain des
jeunes hexagonaux venant suivre une
formation d'excellence dans un
territoire ultramarin si l'on souhaite
créer de la valeur sur place
conformément à votre souhait il faut
s'en donner les moyens enfin Monsieur le
Ministre le constat de l'inadaptation
des normes aux réalités de chaque
territoire est unanime les élus
expriment leur volonté de co-construire
avec le gouvernement pour rendre les
politiques publiques plus eff
c'est aussi un levier indéniable de
création de valeur nous comptons sur
vous je vous remercie merci la parole
est maintenant monsieur Tani Mohamed
fayli pour la commission des lois dont
il est rapporteur pour avis
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues si elle ne
sait pas opposée à l'adoption de crédit
de la mission outre-mer inscrit dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 la
commission des lois a émis des réserves
sur trois points qu'il m'appartient
aujourd'hui de vous présenter tout
d'abord le contexte dans lequel
s'inscrit le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 n'est pas neutre la
persistance de la crise énergétique et
les tensions inflationnistes exacerbes
les problématiques de la vie chère et
les difficultés propres au territoire
ultramarins pourtant force a été de
constater le défaut d'adaptation des
mesures nationales aussi aux
spécificités des collectivités et des
entreprises
ultramarines je ne prendrai qu'un
chiffre pour illustrer cela seul si
communes ultramarine ont bénéficié du
filet de sécurité en 2022 nous appelons
donc à une meilleure prise en compte des
territoires ultramarins dans les
dispositifs proposés pour compenser la
hausse des prix de l'énergie pour les
collectivités comme pour les ménages et
les entreprises pour 2023 nous resterons
vigilants au suivi et à l'application
territorialisée de ces mesures dans nos
autres mères par ailleurs la principale
problématique à laquelle est confronté
la mission outre-mer et celle de la
sous-exécution chronique des crédits
votés bien que des efforts est récemment
été entrepris en la matière cette
situation n'est pas acceptable pour les
citoyens qui ne comprennent pas que les
crédits ne parviennent pas jusqu'à eux
pour les collectivités
ultramarines dont la situation et les
défis imposent une politique
particulièrement volontariste et
pleinement engagée de l'État et pour
nous législateurs qui voyons notre
intention réduite par les
sous-consommations des crédits pourtant
voter voire obtenu de haute luttes dans
l'hémicycle enfin l'accompagnement de
collectivités
ultramarines et aujourd'hui d'autant
plus nécessaire ou égard à la situation
financière et budgétaire fortement
dégradé de certaines collectivités
ultramarines et des risques
d'aggravation qu'emporte le contexte
actuel cela passe par les contrats de
convergence et de transformation qui
doivent impérativement être consommés et
améliorer pour l'avenir par le fond
exceptionnel d'investissement mais
également par le dispositif Corum que
nous vous proposerons de renforcer le
budget 2023 montre ainsi une nouvelle
fois que les problèmes d'ingénierie sur
nos collectivités méritent une réponse
adaptée et volontariste comment annoncer
en commission des lois je déposerai
prochainement une proposition de loi
pour y remédier au bénéfice de ces
observations la commission des lois a
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption de
ces crédits
je vous remercie
dans la suite de l'élection générale je
rappelle que notre parole attribua
chaque groupe pour chacune idée de
discussion concerne inclus aussi le
temps d'explication de vote et que le
gouvernement disposera d'un total de 15
minutes la parole est un ami
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur les reporters
chers collègues les moyens de la mission
outre-mer pour 2023 affiche une hausse
de plus de 300 millions d'euros il faut
s'en réjouir dans cet exercice récurrent
au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale
les parlementaires vous diront monsieur
le ministre rarement merci préférant
vous interpeller sur les attentes des
concitoyens ou les manquements criants
sur le mal logement et l'habitat indigne
qui reste un fléau rappelé par mes
collègues sur l'insécurité avec les
événements de Mayotte et de et en Guyane
sur l'eau potable inégalement partagé en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe sur les
déchets avec des investissements encore
à réaliser pour les collectivités
endettées sur les difficultés des PME
sur la vie chère qu'il s'agisse du prix
du billet d'avion comme du panier de la
ménagère voire de la facture
d'électricité
notre éloignement génère des surcos
permanents causés par la faiblesse
concurrentielle et la situation
oligopolistique consolidée d'année en
année sur l'emploi on vous donnera plus
aisément le chiffre du chômage plutôt
que de rappeler l'augmentation des
creuses iefi ou le travail salutaire du
RSMA non nous ne sommes pourtant pas des
ingrats et si nous arrivent de susciter
de l'agacement chez nos compatriotes de
l'Hexagone qui pensent que l'ampleur
facilement au soleil il est aussi vrai
que les domiens se sentent incompris
aussi permettez-moi à titre liminaire de
rappeler trois grandes considérations la
première nous sommes un archipel qui
demeure une opportunité exceptionnelle
pour la République car être la première
puissance maritime au monde laisse des
perspectives ouvertes sur des trésors
inexploités pour cela nous devons penser
en mairie et non pas en terrien pas
toujours simple quand on sait que l'État
exerce une compétence exclusive sur les
taxes et sur le domaine de la pêche que
l'Union européenne qui a toutes les
compétences les eaux communautaires sans
qu'aucune collectivité ultramarine il
soit associée la deuxième considération
est sans appel nos territoires restent
les territoires les plus inégalitaires
de la République chez nous les salaires
de la fonction publique sont indexés car
la vie est plus chère mais le SMIC est
identique et le chômage plus important
chez nous le foncier est plus rare mais
le prix du mètre carré
identique à la grande capitale
parisienne chez nous c'est la France
mais qu'en est-il entre sur coups de
fret octroie de mer frais de poste
exorbitants et droits de douane
particulier chez nous c'est la France
mais qu'en est-il de ceux qui sont
partis sans espoir de retour en famille
de retour au pays non nos compatriotes
ne sont pas des ingrats mais une large
majorité d'entre eux a exprimé leur
mal-être et leur malaise à travers des
votes extrêmes quand il vous lui dire ce
que nous savons déjà notre modèle
économique monopolistique sur les
échanges commerciaux exclusifs entre la
France et l'Europe n'est plus viable
ainsi que le se termine ce modèle a
permis des progrès évident dans le monde
d'avant mais il a creusé des inégalités
et générer des frustrations et quand
bien même la République reste présente
lors de chaque crise passage d'un
cyclone soulèvement à Mayotte plan
sargasme et austral et grossesse pour
finir la route du littoral aucun
pansement n'arrête une hémorragie que
veulent ces Français de là-bas de la
simplification monsieur le ministre je
vous donne un exemple pour un élu de la
Réunion qui doit appliquer la loi
résidence résidence et climat un
département bloqué entre montagne et
océan fortement contraint par des
couches de protection multiples nous
sommes classés au patrimoine mondial
plus la loi littorale plus la protection
forte des espaces agricoles les risques
naturels très prégnants PPR qui gèle les
possibilités donc difficiles de
compenser les besoins d'extension vous
êtes d'accord avec moi que pour un élu
réunionnais c'est un vrai casse-tête
chinois que veulent ces Français de
là-bas
payez moins cher son électricité
utilisez l'énergie radiative du soleil
pour cela l'aide à l'investissement sur
les énergies renouvelables et
nécessaires comment donc rejoindre
l'autonomie énergétique je sais Monsieur
le Ministre pouvoir compter en tant
qu'enseigne président de la creux pour
répondre favorablement à l'amendement
que j'ai déposé lors de la loi sur les
énergies renouvelables nous voulons vous
l'aurez compris moins de contraintes
normatives de l'adéal de la haute
administration qu'attendre les
ultramarins de leur représentants
politiques que nous sommes tout
simplement qu'on agisse pour qu'ils
vivent mieux pour faire rimer ultramarin
avec
ultra-humain je vous demande de prendre
en compte les différents amendements
portés par mes collègues et moi-même
dont celui qui vise à augmenter les
crédits dédiés à la lutte contre les
violences intrafamidales dans les
outre-mer un signal de votre ministère
serait apprécié au-delà du droit commun
il est temps d'instruire un vrai
changement oui monsieur le ministre à la
création de valeur chiche à la
proposition du ministre Gabriel Attal
faite sur ses bancs pour un nouveau plan
écrit ensemble destiné à tous des
propositions existent déjà qui seront
évoquées par les uns et les autres comme
développer les échanges économiques avec
les bassins régionaux voisins ce qui
oblige quand même le gouvernement à
déléguer des compétences aux
collectivités que nous sommes renforcer
la continuité territoriale pour les
marchandises et les passagers je sais
que la Dom il travaille actuellement
sous la pulsion de votre ministère mais
pensez également à l'aide aux fraises en
clair vous l'aurez compris nous sommes
vitaminés pour travailler avec vous le
groupe UC avec toutes les réserves qui
ont été faites et les amendements votés
votre a ce budget
la parole est un monsieur Stéphane
Artano pour le groupe RDS
le président monsieur le ministre
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues lors des débats sur la
mission outre-mer à l'Assemblée
nationale le 28 octobre dernier monsieur
le ministre vous avez rappelé qu'a
priorité absolue de cette mission
consiste à répondre aux préoccupations
du quotidien en portant une attention
particulière au sujet environnementaux
je tiens tout d'abord à vous encourager
dans cette volonté de réduire les
inégalités entre tous les territoires ce
qui n'est pas une tâche facile il faut
le reconnaître dans un contexte
inflationniste marqué par la menace
d'une crise énergétique majeure
sans oublier les problématiques
sécuritaires les migrations
l'insuffisance du pouvoir d'achat
d'aggravé par la vie chère le chômage de
masse ou encore les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire toutes ces crises
rendent le quotidien ne compatriotes
ultramarins souvent insupportable avant
de traiter ces différents sujets je
souhaite revenir très brièvement sur
quelques chiffres à retenir nous
remarquons globalement une augmentation
de 1,15% des crédits en autorisation
d'engagement et de 0,69% en crédit de
paiement nous en donnons acte bien
évidemment mais elle doit être
relativisée car encore insuffisante tu
égard aux besoins réels et aux
nombreuses problématiques de nos
territoires je sais que vous en êtes
pleinement conscient monsieur le
ministre
nous ne pouvons examiner les crédits de
la mission outre-mer sans aborder des
sujets plus larges comme la question
sécuritaire Mayotte depuis de nombreux
jours une escalade de violence ce coup
Mamoudzou des affrontements entre jeunes
de quartier rivaux on fait un mort un
homme de 20 ans tué à la machette à ça
s'ajoute un bus scolaire attaqué sans
compter le nombre de blessés qui ne
cessent d'augmenter et comme l'on
rappelait nos collègues la député
staliusofa et sénateur Mohamed solili ce
phénomène d'extrême violence ne date pas
d'hier naturellement je m'associe comme
beaucoup ici comme tous aux élus qui
sont démunis et aux habitants de Mayotte
on demeurant en demandant au
gouvernement de rétablir l'ordre le plus
rapidement possible vous revenez d'un
déplacement important monsieur le
ministre avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
et nous sommes sensibles et attentifs
aux annonces qui ont été faites
n'oublions pas que d'autres
collectivités sont également touchées
par ces problématiques sécurité et
d'immigration incontrôlées en Guyane et
aux Antilles l'État doit également
apporter une réponse efficace pour la
protection de nos concitoyens et
préserver l'attractivité de ces
territoires je reviens maintenant à la
vie chère qui ne fait que s'accentuer
dans le territoire les outre-mer
connaissent une situation
socio-économique beaucoup plus
fragilisée par rapport au reste de la
France lors de la rencontre avec les
maires ultramarins au Sénat 21 novembre
dernier de nombreux élus ont à nouveau
alerté sur la dégradation de leur cadre
de vie
en effet les plus modestes souffrent et
sont les premiers touchés par ce fléau
de la vie chère amplifier ces derniers
mois par la hausse des coûts de
l'énergie et des matières premières par
ailleurs il est évidemment inadmissible
que partout sans nos territoires nous
n'ayons pas accès à l'eau aux soins ou
encore un logement décent nous y
reviendrons bien évidemment sur la
discussion donc cadre des amendements
enfin comment ignorer le désarroi de nos
compatriotes
ultramarins face à l'explosion des prix
du billet d'avion entre délégation on va
se pencher dans les prochains mois sur
le sujet de la continuité territoriale
nous savons qu'une réflexion monsieur le
ministre est en cours avec la DOM et que
vos arbitrages seront entendus dans le
courant du premier trimestre 2023 il est
vraisemblable d'ailleurs que à l'avenir
les moyens financiers humains de la Dom
évolueront au fil aux fonctions des
missions qui lui seront confiées voire
le périmètre élargie et nous souhaitons
bien évidemment
le ministre je n'ai pas l'intention ni
la prétention d'être le seul
porte-parole des Outre-mer ici
aujourd'hui comme à l'Assemblée
d'ailleurs cependant je sais que les
populations attendent bien évidemment
des réponses fortes à leurs difficultés
quotidienne à savoir plus de justice
sans oublier une vraie égalité de
traitement entre tous les territoires de
la République nous devons apporter une
réponse commune afin de faire face à
cette fracture sociale pour que la
promesse de fraternité s'y chère à aimer
ses airs et à nos valeurs républicaines
soient tenues je vous sais évidemment
sensible à la réponse de l'État sur ces
sujets fidèle à sa tradition vous
trouverez au Sénat des partenaires
déterminés à accompagner vos réflexions
et en ce sens dans un climat apaisé et
serein ce qui n'a pas toujours été le
cas chez nos collègues de l'Assemblée et
j'ose le dire c'est une tradition
républicaine du Sénat bien évidemment et
vous devez monsieur le Miss vous appuyez
sur cette tradition pour nous permettre
de faire avancer également vos dossiers
réfléchissant aussi monsieur le ministre
a comment améliorer l'exécution des
crédits en nos territoires ça a été
rappelé Georges passion comment
accompagner le développement de
l'ingénierie territoriale pour permettre
à des projets de voir le jour j'ai
rencontré lors du congrès des mères que
ce soit à la MF ou ici au Sénat des
maires qui étaient en plein désarroi
n'ayant aucune réponse pour trouver une
ingénierie sur leur territoire ce qui
interpelle d'ailleurs sur le déploiement
en outre-mer de l'Agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires et sa
questionne vraisemblablement sur son
déploiement chers collègues tout en
restant vigilant aux discussions qui
vont s'ouvrir bien évidemment le groupe
RDSE Vatra en faveur des crédits de
cette mission
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Viviane Mallet pour le groupe les
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues avant
d'entamer l'examen des crédits de la
mission outre-mer je tenais à saluer le
fait que le gouvernement est abondé le
budget initial d'un peu plus de 53
millions d'euros de crédit nouveau issus
des amendements examinés en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale cela va
permettre un renforcement des moyens
consacrés au dispositif Corum à
l'attention des communes en difficulté
de renforcer les développements du RSMA
de compenser la hausse du génère dans
les industries tramarines mais aussi de
renforcer les moyens alloués à la
continuité territoriale à périmètre
constant ce budget est donc en hausse
d'un peu plus de 11%. une hausse non
négligeable soit mais qui sera quasiment
annulée compte tenu des prévisions
d'inflation pour 202
mon intervention portera alors sur deux
thématiques parmi celles qui préoccupent
les populations
ultramarines et mes collègues ici
représentés au Sénat le logement et la
vie chère le logement c'est d'abord un
constat saisissant les logements
indignes représentent près de 13% du
parc de logement dans les outre-mer
contre 1,3 dans l'Hexagone ces logements
insalubles qui exposent leurs occupants
à des risques sur leur sécurité leur
santé et qui entravent ainsi leur vie
quotidienne ces logements sont de plus
en plus présents sur notre territoire
c'est d'ailleurs pour la raison pour
laquelle je propose avec plusieurs de
mes collègues d'augmenter les crédits à
louer à la résorption de l'habitat
indigne et insalubre en outre-mer
puisqu'ils furent sur consommer l'année
dernière par ailleurs 80% des
ultramarins sont éligibles à un logement
social et seulement 15% disposent
le besoin annuel en logement sociaux est
estimé entre 9 et 10.000 le plom 1 est
le plom 2 n'ont pas répondu aux attentes
tout le monde en convient la production
de logements outre-mer est en crise
monsieur le ministre en débit de
l'augmentation de 1,8 % en a eu de la
ligne budgétaire unique nous déplorons
encore une consommation peu efficace des
crédits pour que les crédits de la LBU
soient mieux consommés nous devons
assouplir les procédures qui sont
longues et complexes et mettent en
émettre en écoute d'équation les
financements avec les besoins de la
réalité à la Réunion par exemple les T1
et les T2 sont construits en ont
insuffisants il faut donc
impermativement accès les financements
sur les logements pour les seniors et de
petites surfaces à destination des
jeunes ménages ou des personnes seules
la gouvernance avec une décentralisation
accrue de la gestion de ses crédits
permettra que la BU soit mieux consommer
pour cela la question de l'adaptation
des normes doit être revue et la
question du coût des matériaux doit être
posée car les coûts de construction sont
un frein presque
puisque trop élevé excusez-moi pourquoi
ne pas réfléchir à un bouquet un
bouclier qualité prix sur les prix des
matériaux pour l'habitat il est temps de
redresser là-bas en fin de proposer aux
ultramarins une politique de logements
ambitieuse et efficace à ce titre
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
rendre compte de la réunion avec les
bailleurs sociaux donc vous avez parlé
lors des débats de l'Assemblée nationale
et qui devait se tenir fin novembre mais
le logement c'est aussi l'enru qui doit
impérativement revoir ses maquettes
financières valider avant la crise
sanitaire et économique les conséquences
de la crise covid associée au contexte
insulaire on fait exploser les surcos je
pendais pour exemple la ville de
Saint-Pierre qui a contractualisé avec
leur rue en mars 2020 soit la veille de
la crise covid la ville se voit
désormais contrainte de solliciter une
modification du calendrier ainsi qu'une
subvention supplémentaire de 10 millions
d'euros pour pouvoir finaliser ce
programme de rénovation urbaine je
compte sur l'aide du gouvernement sur ce
dossier le logement c'est aussi l'ananas
parmi les combats qu'il reste amenés il
y a celui du déploiement plein et entier
de l'agence dans les dromes il est
impératif de rendre les propriétaires
occupants ultramarins éligibles aux
aides délivrées par cette organisme le
logement s'est enfin l'habitat
individuel et collectif de nos seniors
qu'il faut adapter rénover et innover
pour l'adapter à nos habitudes de vie
monsieur le ministre faisant écho un
amendement que j'avais déposé le
gouvernement rendu possible le
financement des résidences autonomiques
dans les territoires tramarins avec la
loi du 21 février 2022 dites loi 3DS il
faut désormais que ces structures se
déploient dans nos territoires et je
compte sur vous pour engager cette
dynamique
j'en viens maintenant à la vie chère
dans la feuille de route que vous a
confié le ministre de l'Intérieur une
des priorités de votre ministère et la
lutte contre la vie chère qui doit se
traduire par des résultats sensibles sur
les prix des biens et des services avec
une action particulière non portée sur
les facteurs d'augmentation des plis
monsieur le ministre la qualité des élus
tramarins s'entendent pour dire que la
remise en cause de l'octroi de mer
constitue un danger grave pour les
finances des collectivités locales en
sachant que les recettes de cette taxe
peuvent représenter jusqu'à 40% des
budgets de fonctionnement des communes
cette remise en cause me trait aussi en
danger nos TPE PME qui voit leur
production protégée par rapport aux
produits importés grâce à cette taxe
dans la crise que nous connaissons et
nous paraît plus opportun à l'instar de
ce qui a été fait en Guyane et à Mayotte
d'instaurer une TVA à 0% sur les
produits et services de première
nécessité même si je sais que vous n'y
êtes pas favorable
la vie chère c'est aussi le fret qui
explose la fierté de la vie se sont
aussi les billets d'avion qui flambent
monsieur le ministre vous avez alors
lors des débats l'Assemblée nationale
évoquer des réflexions en cours
sociétématiques ont-elles avancé pour
ouvrir la voie un travail commun je
terminerai mon propos en vous rappelant
monsieur le ministre la promesse du
président de la République sur la hausse
du coefficient géographique afin qu'elle
devienne réalité nous comptons sur votre
soutien car c'est un enjeu majeur pour
les CHU et notamment sud de la Réunion
pour conclure je dirais que les
sénateurs dans leur sagesse habituelle à
monteront ses crédits à louer à
l'Outre-mer et je forme le souhait
monsieur le ministre que si le
gouvernement devanover engager sa
responsabilité sur la première et
deuxième partie du PDF lors de la
navette certains des apports de la Haute
Assemblée soit conservés je vous en
remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur
jean-Louis Lagourgue pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
ces discussions budgétaires relatives
dans un contexte inflationniste et de
renchérissement du coût de l'énergie
alors que nos concitoyens ultramarins
sont déjà fragilisés par de nombreux
facteurs balance commerciale déficitaire
des taux de chômage 2 à 3 fois plus
élevés comme métropole ou encore un
éloignement géographique favorisant la
richesse aussi dans ce contexte
particulier les crédits de la mission
outre-mer doivent être mobilisés plus
que jamais au service de nos territoires
ultramarins ils doivent leur donner les
moyens de leur développement et les
aider à relever les multiples défis
auxquels ils sont confrontés c'est donc
avec satisfaction que je constate que
ces crédits sont en légère augmentation
par rapport à l'année 2022
il serait ainsi pour 2023 à 2,75
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement
et à 2,58 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement soit une augmentation
respectivement de 1,75% en autorisation
d'engagement et un virgule 4 % crédit de
paiement par rapport à 2022 toutefois il
faut souligner que la mission outremer
ne constitue qu'une petite partie du
budget de d'État consacré au territoire
ultramarins en effet la politique
transversale de l'État en direction de
l'outre-mer et portée par 100 programmes
relevant de 32 missions les Forbes
budgétaires de l'État en faveur des
territoires ikramarins s'élèvent ainsi à
20,1 milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et à maintenir 7 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement dans le
cas du projet de loi de finance pour
2023 cela représente une hausse
respectivement de 1,1% et le 3,7% par
rapport à l'année 2022
et cette hausse est la bienvenue car les
besoins sont importants à cet égard je
tiens évoquer la nécessité de faciliter
la station professionnelle des jeunes
ultramarins
des crédits outre-mer cette situation
est extrêmement dommageable lorsqu'on
connaît les besoins impérieux des
territoires ultramarins notamment en
matière du logement et d'emploi il est
primordial de trouver les moyens pour y
remédier
ce ministre mais je suis un collègue les
outre-mer ce sont 12 territoires
français répartis sur les deux ethmices
hémisphères et rayonnant sur trois
océans 12 territoires qui soient la
France nous avons le devoir de parvenir
à instaurer une égalité réelle entre
tout nos territoires afin que chaque
citoyen puisse y vivre avec le sentiment
des partenaires à une seule et même
communauté communauté ce budget y
participe aussi le groupe Les
Indépendants votera les crédits de la
mission outre-mer du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 je vous remercie
merci la parole sera ensuite
à monsieur Guillaume Gontard président
du groupe des écologistes écologistes
solidarité territoire
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mais chers collègues les
crédits de la mission outre-mer dont
augmenté que de 1,71% en autorisation
d'engagement et 1,29% de crédit de
paiement par rapport à la loi de finance
2022 c'est peu pour une mission qui a
pour principal objectif le rattrapage
des écarts persistants entre l'outre-mer
et la métropole a fortiori dans un
contexte de crise économique et sociale
et alors que les inégalités entre les
territoires ultramarins et la métropole
ne cessent de se creuser ainsi
l'effondrement du tourisme entraîne une
situation catastrophique en Polynésie
plus de 20% des Antillais des Guyanais
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
davantage encore à Mayotte 13% des
logements indignes de la France sont en
outre-mer pour 4% de la population comme
l'a montré le rapport que nous avons
commis avec mes collègues Victorin Lurel
et Micheline Jacques je salue l'objectif
de 10000 logements créés ou réhabiliter
chaque année n'était là pas atteint
pourtant 80% des habitants des Outre-mer
sont le logement social mais seul 15% en
bénéficient à ce titre nous regrettons
que les crédits demeure insuffisants
pour résorber l'habitat insalubre et que
l'action logement baisse de
10,57% pardon en crédit de paiement
plutôt que de lutter contre les causes
de la sous-consommation des crédits
outre-mer on réduit les lignes
budgétaires si les collectivités
ultra-maries dans leur part de
responsabilité le manque d'ingénierie de
l'État et la faiblesse du pilotage du
ministère sont aussi en cause comme le
souligner notre rapport nous demandions
l'organisation d'assise du logement
outre-mer et monsieur le ministre nous
n'attendons que votre signal rappelons
aussi que la Cour des comptes estimée en
septembre 2020 que les coûts des
matériaux étaient 20 à 30% supérieur en
outre-mer et encore ça n'a fait que
s'aggraver depuis raison de plus comme
nous suggérions aussi pour renforcer les
filières locales promouvoir les
matériaux biosourcés locaux et une
architecture bioclimatique s'appuyant
sur les savoir-faire traditionnels
comment imaginer dans la septième
puissance économique mondiale des
robinets à sec ou déversant une eau
blanche somatres une eau contaminée au
chlordécone des coupures d'eau
hebdomadaires comme en Guadeloupe des
écoles fermées plus d'un mois par an
faute d'eau en cause des canalisations
vétustes et mal entretenues qui
entraînent un invraisemblable
d'hyperdiction de 60 à 80% de l'eau
capter 70% des stations d'épuration sont
mal entretenues mal surveillés et les
réseaux d'assainissement privé ne sont
pas aux normes cette catastrophe sociale
ne double naturellement d'une
catastrophe écologique le débit des
rivières diminue dangereusement ce qui
menace la continuité écologique et
dépend entier de la biodiversité les
nappes phréatiques souvent contaminées
au corps des cônes risque en outre la
salinisation
la pêche est interdite en Martinique
dans de nombreux cours d'eau à cause du
chlordécone et les récifs corréliens
souffrent grandement l'ARS donne
l'alerte à ce rythme d'ici 10 ans il n'y
aura plus de coins de baignade de grande
qualité en Guadeloupe un désastre
écologique touristique donc économique
est en germe le cas des Antilles est
symptomatique mais j'aurais pu parler
des eaux contaminées ou au mercure en
Guyane votre prédécesseur a promis 170
millions d'euros pour les réseaux
Guadeloupéens là où il en faudrait 600
voir 700 il ambitionnait de régler le
problème en 5 ans monsieur le ministre
il faut accélérer financement à générer
main d'oeuvre l'étoile doit suppléer les
collectivités les collectivités locales
partout c'est nécessaire il faut mettre
en place une gestion publique de l'eau
et cesser de confier ce commun précieux
à la prédation de Veolia et consort un
mot pour finir de la protection de la
biodiversité
ultramarine qui concerne plus de 90% des
espèces présentes sur le territoire
national selon les estimations de l'ofb
ce sont 500 000 à 1 million d'espèces
qui sont menacées de disparition
monsieur le ministre nous manquons
grandement de visibilité dans le PLF sur
les crédits destinés spécifiquement à la
protection de la biodiversité
ultramarine ceci est d'autant plus
problématique que la France vient
d'annoncer un renforcement de ces aires
marines protégées d'une manière générale
ne serait-il pas préférable que la
protection de la biodiversité
ultramarine fasse loger d'un programme
face l'objet pardon d'un programme
spécifique de la mission budget
budgétaire d'outre-mer avec toutes les
réserves et énoncées et en souhaitant
que les avancées du Sénat résistent aux
49-3 le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire votera cependant pour ce
budget merci merci
la parole est à Monsieur Dominique
Théophile pour le groupe RDPI
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues l'examen des crédits de
la mission outre-mer du projet de loi de
finance est un moment toujours
particulier pour nous sénateur
ultramarins je dis non parce que c'est
des bas s'ils sont scrutés dans nos
territoires nature généralement pas les
foules dans cette hémicycle les attentes
et les enjeux sont pourtant nombreux
puisqu'il s'agit de combler le retard de
développement puis sur l'hexagone en
matière d'emploi et de conditions de vie
cette année l'examen de la mission
aurait peut-être une dimension
supplémentaire c'est une année de
renouvellement sénatorial c'est aussi la
première fois depuis deux ans que nous
nous réunissons pour un débattre avec
2,75 milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement le budget du ministère des
Outre-mer enregistre pour 2023 une
légère hausse de 1,4 par rapport à la
loi de finance initiale pour 2022 un
périmètre constant c'est toute
supérieure à 11% qu'il nous faut saluer
dans le détail la mission outre-mer
bénéficie d'un budget résolument tourné
vers l'emploi la hausse des crédit du
programme 138 au titre de la
compensation des exonérations de
cotisation sociale patronales et bien
sûr une satisfaction elle permettra de
renforcer la compétitivité des
entreprises ultramarines et de soutenir
l'emploi dans les secteurs stratégiques
autre motif de réjouissance la forte
progression des moyens à l'aide à
l'insertion et à la qualification
professionnelle portée par le
déploiement du plan SMA 2025
les quelques 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront mobilisés
permettront de poursuivre les projets
Entreprises cette année à Mayotte et en
Polynésie française notamment enfin la
Dom poursuivra la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord cadre national avec Paul
emplois et au centre ras ses actions de
formation sur des filières stratégiques
et d'avenir comme la transition
écologique et le numérique second volet
de la mission le programme 123
conditions de vie outre-mer enregistre
ou 2023 une hausse de 4 millions d'euros
de la ligne budgétaire unique consacrée
au logement social augmentation qui
permettra de poursuivre la dynamique
impulsée par le plan logement outre-mer
ce dont nous nous réjouissons évidemment
ce budget se caractérise surtout par le
renforcement substantiel du soutien
collectivité avec 34 et 50 millions
d'euros supplémentaires en autorisation
d'engagement et un crédit de paiement
avec le métier à niveau des crédits des
contrats de convergence et de
transformation et le financement de la
sub à la collectivité territoriale de
Guyane ce soutien collectivité se
traduira également par un effort
exceptionnel de 30 millions d'euros pour
soutenir le syndicat mixte de l'eau et
de l'assainissement en Guadeloupe c'est
une satisfaction mais j'y reviendrai
dans quelques instants notons également
la poursuite de l'action de l'État en
matière d'assistance technique et de
soutien les génériques pour la
concrétisation des projets structurants
des territoires ultramarins et des forts
déployés pour répondre aux problèmes de
sous-consommation de crédit que nous
votons chaque année au-delà de nos
talents locaux nos collectivités doivent
se saisir des outils d'hôtel dispose je
pense notamment à l'agence de la
cohésion des territoires je me réjouis
également de la contribution du
ministère à la lutte contre les algues
Sargasses et au programme d'intervention
territoriales de l'État ainsi que de la
prise en charge de la totalité des
investissements des services publics
antisargasses qui viennent d'être créés
en Guadeloupe et en Martinique c'est
bien bien sûr un motif de satisfaction
la création de ces services publics
faisait un effet partie des
recommandations contenues dans mon
rapport de 2019 sur la question c'est
une étape importante mais c'est une
étape qui doit être suivie d'une seconde
à savoir le stockage des algues les
teneurs en arsenic et parfois encore des
cônes font en effet craindre une
pollution des sols et des eaux à
proximité des sites de stockage il nous
faut avancer sur cette problématique et
là encore dans le rapport monsieur le
ministre vous avez une préconisation qui
consiste à endiguer c'est la
problématique du stockage sur nos
territoires
un regret est quelque soit pour terminer
sur la question de l'eau en Guadeloupe
d'abord j'en ai parlé à l'instant les
moyens avancés 30 millions d'euros
devront s'accompagner d'une vision mais
aussi d'un engagement pluri annuel de
l'État c'est là selon moi le seul moyen
de retrouver la sérénité nécessaire et
de régler définitivement cette question
qui au-delà des moyens qui sont mis à
notre disposition et bien en brasse un
peu nos territoires sur la façon dont
nous allons pouvoir mobiliser le
financement des souhaits enfin sur le
périmètre de la mission outre-mer nous
sommes nombreux sur ces bancs à
regretter chaque année que ce crédit ne
représente que 13% de la mobilisation du
budget de l'État faveur de notre
territoire le périmètre exhaustif des
crédits comprend en effet sans un
programme budgétaire relevant de 32
mission en 2023 c'est plus de 20
milliards d'euros qui seront estimés
pour les outre-mer en hausse de 1,1% en
autorisation d'engagement et 3,7% crédit
de paiement c'est beaucoup et pourtant
nous ne disposons pas à ce jour d'un
espace de discussion sur le budget qui
fonde le développement de nos
territoires les crédits qui ne subissent
pas dans la mission outre-mer
c'est-à-dire les 87% ne doivent pas
passer sous silence et échapper au débat
politique il nous faudra pouvoir un jour
discuter de la réalité de nos
territoires de nos aspirations de nos
différences la question de la sécurité
de l'éducation et de la santé ne se pose
pas en effet dans les mêmes termes que
l'on soit à Mayotte en Polynésie
française ou en Guadeloupe une vision
moderne de l'approche but qui était un
doit émerger et monsieur le ministre je
vous soumet une idée qui vous que vous
avez peut-être déjà en tête une approche
budgétaire renouvelée doit aller de pair
avec une nouvelle loi d'orientation et
de programmation pour les outre-mer vous
l'aurez compris notre groupe vodka de
crédit de cette mission et soutiendra
les amendements déposés par les
rapporteurs spéciaux je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant Madame
Catherine goncone pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord
monsieur le ministre vous dit que je
salue certains états d'esprit qui
préside désormais aux relations entre
les élus et le ministère de la vie
outre-mer depuis la mission de votre
prédécesseur et vous avez heureusement
maintenu cette ambiance globale je tiens
à vous dire que j'apprécie la réactivité
la proximité l'écoute et forcément une
plus grande attention donc une meilleure
compréhension de nos peuples singuliers
la prise en compte de nos cultures de
nos expressions de ne pas passer
douloureux droit présidé au traitement
de notre quotidien votre budget est en
augmentation monsieur le ministre
j'aurais pu m'en contenter ma satisfaire
et non j'aimerais qu'on aille plus loin
plus que les sommes importantes affectés
à votre mission les intentions compte
encore Dav me concernant je crois aux
intentions fortes monsieur le ministre
je crois aux intentions afficher
concrète de plus de justice et d'équité
c'est le sens donné aux amendements que
j'ai déposé ils ne seront pas de nature
à vous dire mettez plus il vous demande
de vous engager de tenir des objectifs
et de vous adresser au quotidien de nos
peuples un quotidien qui rime avec taux
de pauvreté qui augmentent Vichères
vieillissement et baisse de la
population en particulier pour la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique au travers
des amendements j'ai voulu vous demander
de sanctuariser une somme pour
l'accompagnement dans le logement social
les bailleurs sociaux sont aux abois non
pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de sous
pour construire mais parce qu'ils sont
désormais confrontés à l'immense
difficulté du vivre ensemble la LBU
mérite de veiller à cela aussi en leur
demandant en leur donnant pardon les
moyens d'assumer désormais les nouveaux
métiers qui leur incombe de fait
assistance sociale psychiatre geote
travailleurs familial j'évolue aussi
dans mes demandes vous demandez
d'afficher une intention forte pour
assurer une meilleure mobilité de nos
populations en situation de grande
injustice et encore plus dans ce
contexte d'augmentation énorme
importante du prix des tarifs aériens il
faudra favoriser le retour et en
particulier en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique moins
4500 personnes par an dans les rangs des
Martiniquais il faut donc face à cette
saignée un dispositif exceptionnel face
tout simplement à des peuples envoient
des disparition les départs ont été
organisés par l'État entre les années 60
et 80 c'était la seule réponse apportée
aux maldéveloppement partez partez aller
ailleurs et bien monsieur le ministre il
faudra organiser le retour des hommes
mais même dispositif qui a servi à
signer ses peuples à les remplir de
nouveau je vous informe que d'après un
sondage très sérieux organisé auprès de
6000 de nos ressortissants
85% d'entre eux veulent rentrer dans
leur pays nos peuples ont soif
d'entendre des mots forts des intentions
ferment des objectifs évaluables les
collectivités locales il y a qui souvent
on se retourne y compris l'État qui nous
dit voyez avec les collectivités pousse
à fond leurs moyens elles ne peuvent
plus continuer à éponger une pauvreté
qui augmente sans cesse et en
particulier en cette période de forte
inflation
écoutez-nous monsieur le ministre
lorsque nous nous portons nous
amendements faites confiance à nos
analyses elles ont le bon sens de la
connaissance exceptionnelle de nos
compatriotes et du terrain ne les
sanctionnez pas systématiquement par
ne sanctionnez pas systématiquement nos
propositions pour un droit au bonheur de
nos compatriotes par une implacable et
froid à vie défavorable ne soyez pas
défavorable à l'équité monsieur le
ministre ne soyez pas défavorable à la
justice ne soyez pas défavorable au
mieux et au mieux vivre de nos peuples
ces peuples au mauvais sommeil rompus ne
soyez tout simplement pas défavorable à
l'esprit de la République je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre et pour le
fait que je crois en l'humain je crois
l'homme et que j'ai envie de moins en
moins d'entendre craquer les os de ses
impérialiste j'ai envie de vous faire
confiance et pour cela je voterai votre
budget
la parole est à Madame à la présidente
de la nacie pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur je tiens à souligner
l'augmentation de plus de 2,7 milliards
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement des
crédits à louer à la mission outre-mer
les dispositifs de soutien exceptionnel
aux collectivités d'outre-mer son
renforcés permettant ainsi d'élargir la
liste des bénéficiaires sur la témoigne
effectivement de la bonne volonté du
gouvernement de se soucier enfin de tous
les territoires de la République mais
est suffisant pour faire face à
l'ampleur des enjeux et de la détresse
vient d'être dit aussi des habitants
situés en outre-mer la première journée
du 104e congrès des maires à Paris était
dédié à l'Outre-mer l'importance des
territoires ultramarins et l'inquiétude
de nos élus locaux face aux enjeux et
problématiques des territoires n'est pas
une mince affaire et mérite une forte
attention et le déploiement de grands
moyens dans ces territoires doublement
touchés par la crise économique
énergétique écologique sanitaire et dont
retard de développement ne pourra pas se
compenser d'ausito les communes et les
élus locaux aux besoins d'un
accompagnement fort pour mettre en place
des politiques publiques assurer leur
mission première de service public et
lutter contre la pauvreté grandissante
l'inflation a dépassé les 10% la vie est
chère le pouvoir d'achat diminue la
population est en détresse les
mobilisations populaires continuaient le
calme n'est malheureusement pas près de
revenir les produits alimentaires sont
entre 28 et 38% plus élevés qu'en
métropole le taux de pauvreté en
outre-mer varie entre 33 et 77% contre
14% dans l'Hexagone les citoyens et les
citoyens des Outre-mer demande une
égalité de traitement et veulent qu'on
les considère comme tous les autres pour
cela il est elle doit pouvoir travailler
trouver un emploi vecteur fondamental
pour lutter contre cette pauvreté et
vivre dignement mais comment compenser
un tel retard quand on sait que le
niveau de vie médian est inférieur de
presque 30% à celui en hexagone les
valeurs sont bas par rapport à des
emplois similaires dans l'Hexagone donc
alors même que la vie est plus chère
dans les outre-mer dans le rapport
présenté en commission je note et je
salue l'adoption d'un amendement
majorant les moyens alloués à la
résorption de l'habitat insalubre en
outre-mer en effet le logement et
l'habitat sont des sujets assujettis à
des problématiques grandissantes la
rareté du foncier le réchauffement
climatique et ses conséquences la
croissance démocratie démographique
étant d'autres tout cela implique ou
témoignent qu'il faut une témoigne
plutôt qu'il faut une politique du
logement forte notamment pour construire
plus de logements sociaux mais également
pour lutter et c'est une grande bataille
contre l'habitat en ligne ce sont de ce
fait les services publics qui sont
impactés les ressources sont manquantes
et les inégalités entre l'hexagone et
les outre-mer son frappantes les déserts
médicaux sont de plus en plus présent
tous les hôpitaux sont en détresse le
service public de la santé manque le
développement de l'économie locale est
indispensable pourtant pour permettre à
déménage et à notre jeunesse de sortir
de cette spirale et trouver un emploi je
le redis je salue l'augmentation des
crédits de la mission outre-mer mais il
faut réellement qu'on lutte contre les
différences de traitement et prioriser
des sujets l'égalité républicaine doit
exister pour tout et pour tous ces
territoires veulent se développer avoir
leur destin en main les jeunes veulent
étudier dans de bonnes conditions
s'insérer dans le milieu professionnel
dépasser ce plafond de verre et
construire leur vie ils ont besoin de
soutien et ils ont besoin d'écoute
monsieur le ministre ce ne sont pas des
décisions prises par le haut qui
permettront de comprendre les
problématiques entre guillemets du bas
il faut faire avec celles et ceux
confrontés aux difficultés quotidiennes
il faut faire avec les mères avec avec
les élus dans leur diversité qui
demandent un dialogue et de la
Coopération les représentants de l'État
doivent entendre les revendications et
adapter leur propositions en fonction
des territoires nous avons dans la
continuité de ces mots déposer des
amendements pour mettre en lumière
quelques difficultés rencontrées par les
populations d'outre-mer notamment contre
la vie chère l'accès à l'eau et l'aide
aux désamiantage pour protéger les
habitants nous en discuterons tout à
l'heure madame la Première ministre a
annoncé mardi qu'un conseil
interministériel des Outre-mer ce
tiendrait au printemps pour suivre
l'évolution de ces engagements nous y
serons attentifs et nous serons bien sûr
aux côtés de celles et ceux qui ont
besoin d'être écoutés chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris il y a du progrès
avec l'augmentation des crédits de cette
mission mais maintenant il faut des
actes forts face à la réalité au
quotidien des habitants ultramarins qui
subissent depuis des années ces
inégalités ces défaillances
structurelles et ce manque de
considération pour autant mon groupe ne
s'opposera pas à
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard podja
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
merci tout d'abord de votre présence ici
aujourd'hui
à peine le revenu du caillou où vous
avez avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer monsieur Darmanin
travaillé au retour du dialogue entre
toutes les parties calaison
c'est très important à ce moment de
notre histoire
votre présente présente ce témoigne de
votre considération vis-à-vis de la
représentation sénatoriale
le projet de loi de finance que nous
examinons traduit l'intention du
gouvernement de Dieu ne compatriotes
ultramarins à faire face à un contexte
international particulièrement
défavorable qui aggravent les
difficultés déjà considérables le nos
territoires je salue en particulier les
moyens à louer au plan SMA 2025 ainsi
que la lutte contre le changement
climatique dans le Pacifique
monsieur le ministre mon propos sera
précis
il faut désormais traduire dans les
faits l'une des recommandations du
rapport d'informations de l'Assemblée
nationale du 3 octobre 2019 sur la
continuité territoriale dans les
outre-mer j'invite donc le gouvernement
à l'appliqué effectivement
l'article L
1803-4 du code de transport sur la
continuité territoriale intérieure
aujourd'hui seule la Guyane bénéficie de
ce dispositif
s'il est indispensable à ce territoire
le bénéficier de certaines contenus de
difficultés qui lui sont inhérentes cela
s'entend également pour la Polynésie
française dans le territoire intérieur
est composé de 118 îles répartis sur 5,5
millions de kilomètres carrés cela vaut
bien sûr pour les îles de l'archipel
calédonien j'ai population de l'IFU le
marais de Tiga d'où vient le Bel-Air et
de l'île des Pins devons aujourd'hui
prendre l'avion ou le Mazo pour accéder
à des services publics essentiels lycée
université hôpital de marge
administrative etc les habitants des
îles de Futuna
impérativement besoin de rejoindre
régulièrement l'île de Wallis l'histoire
de 250 km enfin certains services
notamment médicaux ne sont accessibles
aux habitants de Wallis ou Futuna qu'on
se rendent à Nouméa distance de
2100 km
l'extension de l'aile de la continuité
territoriale au déplacement interril
permettrait d'éviter l'exode des
populations vers papeet et Nouméa
rassurer le développement économique et
de désenclavagement de ce territoire
monsieur le ministre je vous assure que
le population en difficulté sociale ont
vraiment besoin de l'application de ce
dispositif je pense particulièrement à
nos anciens et à nos jeunes je compte
sur votre détermination pour mettre fin
à cette injustice entre les outre-mer je
vous remercie
la parole est maintenant madame Annick
Pétrus pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'examen de crédits de la mission
d'outre-mer et l'occasion pour moi de
vous livrer l'état d'esprit de beaucoup
de collègues des territoires ultramarins
si nous pouvons nous féliciter d'un
budget en augmentation et le ministre
qui connaît apprécient les territoires
nous avons vite commencé à déchanter
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023
fatigué nous sommes devoir opposer des
fins de non-recevoir avec des arguments
qui démontrent la méconnaissance de nos
territoires et des difficultés que
rencontre ce qui vivent difficultés qui
pour la plupart n'existent plus dans
l'Hexagone depuis bien longtemps
fatigué nous sommes au fur et à mesure
des rejets de nos
confrontés à ce sentiment d'intimité et
à l'impression souvent de mendier alors
même que nous demandons relève du doigt
primaire de nous administrer comme ce
soigner se loger décemment et de
l'économie pour donner un emploi chaque
et avec cette emploi un peu de dignité
une école ou du moins un système
scolaire leur permettant de réussir en
reconnaissant et en prenant contre les
particularités existantes sur les
territoires
au-delà de ce manque de connaissance des
territoires ultramarins nous devons
aussi faire face à des injustices
incomprises par nos concitoyens qui se
tournent de plus en plus vers les
extrêmes en effet comment expliquer le
rejet systématique du gouvernement
d'aligner le taux de réduction d'impôts
pour les investissements en faveur de la
rénovation hôtelière en dépit de la
situation du Nil du manque de chambre
d'hôtel disponible de l'état de son
économie du taux de chômage et du
désavantage qu'elle a vis-à-vis de ses
voisins qui ne sont pas soumis aux
normes strictes imposées au territoire
web comment expliquer que les gens
continuent à mourir à Saint-Martin faute
de pouvoir être transféré vers le CHU le
plus proche après 18h une solution n'a
toujours pas été trouvée pour garantir
ses évacuations sanitaires comme
autoriser les vols après 18h à
l'aéroport de Grand Case
mais nous ne cédrons pas aux pessimiste
car tout n'est pas noir évidemment
nous continuons d'espérer alors telles
sont quelques vœux pour Saint-Martin
monsieur le ministre la mise en place du
bouclier tarifaire à Saint-Martin afin
que la péréquation tarifaire en place
depuis 1975 et garantie par la
convention cadre de 2001 ne soit pas
dans les faits remis en cause la
conception est mise en place courant
2023 d'un dispositif de remise
automatique sur le prix du carburant
dans les trois comme de l'Atlantique
l'instauration du chèque énergie dès
l'an prochain
l'octroi à partir de 2023 à l'instar de
la com de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon d'une
dotation exceptionnelle et plurielle de
2,7 millions d'euros sur 6 ans au titre
de la RSI
errachi contenu des problématiques de
logement
la compensation rétroactive par l'état
des charges transférées en 2012
logements et habitat à minima 17,4
millions d'euros sur 10 ans et qui n'a
toujours pas été à ce jour compensé
l'augmentation de
49,5 % à 53,5 % du taux de réduction
d'impôts pour les investissements en
faveur de la rénovation hôtelière à
l'instar des investissements de même
nature réalisée dans les DOM
la révision courant 2023 de la
convention de gestion comme DG FIP de
mars 2008 et la mise en place
d'applications informatiques adaptée à
la fiscalité saint-martinoise avec
l'assistance humaine financière et
technique conformément recommandations
de la mission interministérielle de
juillet 2015 mais aussi du référé de la
Cour des comptes de décembre 2017
enfin le réengagement de l'État à
travers l'administration des douanes il
ne reste que deux douaniers à
Saint-Martin monsieur le ministre donc
plus de contrôle effectif sur le
territoire car si nous avons été riches
en collectivité d'outre-mer au sens de
l'article 74 de la Constitution notre
statue au sens du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne n'a
pas été modifié c'est Martin reste une
région ultra périphérique de l'Union
européenne et se situe dans le
territoire douanier communauté voici
Monsieur le Ministre ainsi présenté les
actions prioritaires pour Saint-Martin
qui pourrait nous redonner un peu
d'espoir
ne laissez pas la géographie décider de
qui est citoyen Français à part entière
ou entièrement à part je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Victor jasmin pour 4 minutes pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues et mes
chers collègues rapporteur vous
comprendrez bien que à ce stade je peux
être redondante et je ferai de façon
très synthétique mais j'apprécie tout ce
qui a été dit par l'ensemble de ces
bancs par mes collègues
monsieur le ministre le budget est
augmentation certes sera-t-il à la
hauteur des besoins et en jupe qui
s'impose désormais aux élus ultramarins
telle est la question je souhaite
insister sur certaines problématiques
qui sont malheureusement encore
d'actualité et qui me tiennent
particulièrement à cœur en premier lieu
la question du pouvoir d'achat qui reste
la principale préoccupation des familles
d'outre-mer avec la vie chère il est
important d'adapter la composition du
panier bouclier qualité prix aux
habitudes de consommation de chacune de
nos territoires de même l'augmentation
du prix des carburants aujourd'hui
premier décembre 2022 et bien le prix
des carburants
du gaz et bien sa flamme en Guadeloupe
donc ce n'est pas normal entre les
volontés affichées apparentes et la
réalité du territoire et bien vous voyez
entre la digue et le fer il y a la mer
et d'ailleurs le rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances sur la régulation
du prix du carburant et du gaz dans les
départements d'outre-mer que je vais
avais demandé et encore sous un bargo un
amendement a été pris ici même justement
pourquoi cet embargo se lève et bien
malheureusement eh bien c'est l'opacité
on ne sait pas pourquoi j'assure
également votre attention sur la
formation des jeunes il est essentiel de
mettre en œuvre des mesures
d'accompagnement pour les entreprises
afin de créer des emplois pérennes et
garder les forces vives sur une autre
territoire et sur l'ensemble des
territoires d'ailleurs l'orientation et
l'affectation des élèves est
fondamentale pour éviter de dépupment à
moyen terme et ce qui à terme serait
irréversible c'est malheureux qu'on l'a
dit mais aussi Michel pour ce faire la
mise en adéquation entre d'une par la
formation au métier en tension avec
d'autre part les besoins des entreprises
constituent un des leviers pour atténuer
le chômage et en fait il convient
d'assurer différenciation effective par
la mise en cohérence des différentes
normes auxquelles sont soumises nos
différents territoires et collectivités
d'outre-mer par rapport au risque
naturel majeur par rapport au contraire
zéro artificiel utilisation net mais
aussi par rapport à la nécessité de
maintenir l'équilibre du foncier
agricole pour la souveraineté
alimentaire mais aussi énergétique
l’évoquerai en dernier point c'est la
compagnement des collectivités
territoriales les différentes
collectivités d'ailleurs qui ont besoin
de la foi de budget mais aussi que
l'État prenne toutes ces responsabilités
à leur côté vous l'avez entendu
récemment monsieur le ministre les élus
locaux lors du congrès des maires et
bien ils ont mis en évidence les
différentes problématiques qui sont les
leurs aussi monsieur la ministre il
serait souhaitable après le gouvernement
prennent en fait en compte les
différents éléments en fonction des
besoins spécifiques de chaque de nos
territoires pour que plus nous puissions
tous ensemble bénéficier de votre
accompagnement merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Jean-François caraco monsieur
le ministre délégué chargé des autres
mères c'est à vous
présidente
c'est pour la première fois dans cette
chambre et après quelques mois après ma
prise de fonction
sous l'autorité de Gérald Darmanin que
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter ce
budget outre-mer
dans les crédits augmentent sensiblement
mission résolument tournée vers le
quotidien et l'avenir tout à la fois je
dirais le quotidien l'avenir de ce que
désormais j'ai envie d'appeler nos
concitoyens de la France océanique
j'avais imaginé l'archipel France votre
collègue créateur patient m'a dit ça va
pas du tout
la Guadeloupe la Guyane n'est pas une
île bon
donc je suis peut-être je vais essayer
d'imposer la France océanique je pense
que c'est bien
ultramarin me paraît un peu inexact mais
on va regarder
ces moyens sont en hausse de 300
millions d'euros dans le texte initial
désormais 353 suite au débat de
l'Assemblée nationale soit plus 13%
c'est un grand art a dit que c'était
1% il faut regarder les périmètres à
périmètre égale en rajoutant ce qu'on a
défiscalisé on est bien à
13%, si on prend en compte les 53
millions de plus et non plus 11%
pour la première fois on va tutoyer les
3 milliards d'engagements mais il est
vrai un des intervenants indiqués que
cette souhaitable qu'on a global sur
tout ce qui concourt
la participation de l'État à la vie de
cette France océanique et gardez
peut-être les périmètres c'est un autre
débat
mais il est là j'ai voulu articuler la
présentation de ces crédits de la
mission de la France océanique autour de
quatre priorités
mais je vais vous dire je vous dis en
réponse à certaines interventions que je
ne me sens pas là
Niger al Darmanin non plus
pour remplacer les collectivités locales
on se met on discute puis on se met
ensemble et on se met derrière elle
moi le plus grand jacobin de la
République
outre-mer je suis pour être derrière les
collectivités locales et non pas de vent
donc on discute et on essaye de le faire
ensemble le sénateur vous savez que
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire à Mayotte
notamment
c'est déjà beaucoup d'être derrière mais
je tiens pas être devant
ma première
priorité c'est de répondre aux
préoccupations du quotidien avec une
intention particulière sur les sujets
environnementaux vous l'avez tous noté
30 millions pour accompagner syndicat
mix en charge de l'eau et
l'assainissement en Guadeloupe je veux
le dire à ceux qui en doutent encore
moi je fais un peu confiance aux élus
locaux on s'est mis d'accord on s'est vu
ils vont le faire le 9 décembre tout
sera sera bien calé l'assistance
technique sera sur place je reviendrai
sur l'assistance technique tout à
l'heure et on aura fait un pas
gigantesque gigantesque en Guadeloupe
mais sur l'ensemble des financements de
l'eau parce qu'on parle de Mayotte aussi
moi je voudrais dire qu'entre 2016 et
2022 sur l'eau ce sont 280 millions
d'euros de subventions qui ont été
donnés sur l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarins plus 335 millions de prêts
plus 10 millions d'euros d'assistance
technique c'est pas rien alors on va
passer la sur multipliée
notamment
en Guadeloupe je viens de le dire et à
Mayotte où j'ai signé quand j'ai été à
Mayotte 411 millions
et je veux répondre à travers vous
députés
que moi j'attends la demande
de DUP à Mayotte pour la lancer elle a
été retirée monsieur le sénateur vous le
savez donc on avance mais je suis
derrière
je ne veux pas être devant je suis
autre mesure qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et qui a été
salué
la mise en place du service public
anti-cergasse avec un cofinancement à
80% de l'État 5 millions d'euros pour
2023 une contribution de mon ministère
au programme intermittaire de lutte
moteur de 3,5 millions c'est
qui complète
on est sur la bonne voie les trois
services publics sont en place
sont en place sans les discuté encore il
y a peu avec chacun des présidents
pour répondre à madame la sénatrice de
Saint-Martin je dirais que le président
Washington est en
en tête de ce combat et il le fait bien
donc on va y arriver aussi en matière de
logement
les moyens ont été renforcés autour de 4
millions
comme la rappeler madame la Première
ministre là c'est nationale nous n'avons
pas de gestion restrictive de cette LBU
moi je me félicite en engagement on a un
problème après de CP mais on a eu on a
pour la première fois en 2021-2022 20 21
22 engagé toutes les AE
c'est bien c'est pas suffisant si les
projets sont là on ira plus loin on l'a
fait en gestion les derniers et madame
la Première ministre a rappelé qu'elle
voulait le faire aussi en 2023 mais il y
a des points de blocage vous avez tous
souligné
les propositions concrètes
pour recenser ses points de blocage des
propositions concrètes encouragées à
produire plus et plus vite de logements
sociaux et très sociaux j'ai eu la
semaine dernière une conférence avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du logement les
sociétés HLM et assimilés
de l'aménagement du territoire et de la
rénovation urbaine pour moi c'est la
bonne méthode ce n'est pas une question
de moyens financier mais une question de
l'unité des volontés
je suis défavorable à une un plan
général outre-mer désormais
il nous faut maintenant travailler
territoire par territoire on va voir les
blocages j'y reviendrai dans les suites
du 7 septembre il est énorme et de
l'appel de Fort-de-France on va les voir
mais mettre tous ces territoires
ensemble pour parler tous ensemble de
logement
passera une après-midi pas très agréable
d'une part et de taf pas sûr que ce soit
efficace
il y a 4 quand même je vous ai dit qu'il
y a quatre points d'application qui
méritent une attention renforcée
Mamoun joue et Congo sur lesquels je
discute avec les deux mères avec le
président de la collectivité
territoriale pour avoir une méthode un
peu comme la rue d'Aubagne à Marseille
si j'ose dire
et une mission se rendra là-bas pour
regarder ce sujet de même d'ailleurs que
les sujets de circulation qui sont quand
même je vais vous dire
à Mayotte tout le monde nous parle de
l'insécurité évidemment que c'est une
vraie volonté on va voir dans la loi
immigration on va voir sur les moyens
renforcés
et j'ai un sujet d'hôpital
c'est un sujet de circulation à
Mamoudzou il faut 4h le matin on se lève
à 4h pour aller travailler à 8h puis il
faut 4 heures pour rentrer
on a un problème de porc on a un
problème de logement le bidonville c'est
ça que ce soit et c'est parce qu'on
travaillera tout ça qu'on arrivera à
régler un sécurité au moins pour partie
ça y contribue
Mayotte point particulier
Pointe-à-Pitre et Fort de France sur la
réhabilitation
des centres-villes
à Pointe-à-Pitre mais j'ai eu les deux
mers les deux présidents de
collectivités on est partant on va
essayer comme je dis de faire un pack et
nous derrière eux et nous derrière pour
travailler sur ces réhabilitations avec
la guerre et
j'attends on va le faire
quatrième point d'attention
Saint-Laurent du Maroni ça nous rend du
Maroni qui je pense la ville de France
qui grossit le plus vite ces
gigantesques qui grossit le plus vite il
va nous falloir d'ailleurs régler les
problèmes fonciers s'agissant de la
continuité territoriale c'est un sujet
sensible vous l'avez dit les moyens
progresses de 7 millions en 2023 par
rapport à 2022 c'est peut-être passé je
veux simplement rappeler les problèmes
qui sont les miens
la survie des compagnies ça coûte
environ quelques centaines de millions
d'euros à l'État Air Austral
corsaire Air Caraïbes et maintenant
er Guyane qui est en des confitures on
paye on dit pas
si on marie pasula on a fait le job
et sur Saint-Martin le balisage est en
cours et donc on pourra faire des
évasions de la nuit c'était ça le sujet
c'est le sujet
dont vous m'aviez parlé dans le
président Washington m'avait saisi enfin
j'ai une difficulté et c'est la Dom on
va renouveler ça y est on va avoir un
directeur de la Dom il est choisi un
président de la domin il est choisi donc
ça sera pas inutile d'augmenter les
moyens comme vous l'avez fait et ça sera
pas utile d'avoir une politique à la Dom
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
et je pense qu'on va y arriver il va
être nommé la directeur dans les 8 jours
en tout cas avant la avant la fin de
l'année un mot sur Wallis
parce que c'est de la République
d'offrir à chacun des conditions de
vigne de Viking nous avons prévu
sur le transport de faire des choses sur
le port de foutuna on est dans des
débats ahurissants avec la Commission
européenne j'espère qu'on va gagner mais
toujours difficile les financements
européens c'est sympa mais il faut être
bien carré derrière
mais on va le faire mais j'ai un
problème à foutouna c'est qu'il y a plus
une compagnie qui veut les desservir
il y a plus une compagnie qui veut des
servir entre Wallis et Futuna
alors c'est bien mais ça tombe encore
sur le ministère de l'Outre-mer
et j'aurais préféré derrière que devant
je le dis enfin parce que c'est notre
honneur nous avons prévu deux millions
cinq pour financer les petites retraites
et les minimas sociaux à wallisia Futuna
parce que c'était quand même un scandale
absolu
deuxième priorité de ce budget la
création de valeur sur chaque territoire
les contrats de plan
j'ai déjà parlé 10 minutes
c'est pas du tout il vous reste 4
minutes
prenez votre temps ne vous laissez pas
perturber intéressant ce qu'on raconte
mais
création de valeur sur chaque territoire
les contraintes plein arrivée échéance
en 2022 ils seront prolongés en avenant
par avenant en 2023 avec une
contribution de l'État stabilisé c'est
un effort budgétaire de 530 millions 530
millions pommes en 2023 et on va tout au
long de l'année 2023 préparé ce 2024 ah
c'est pas la prochaine génération à
partir de 2024
voici le moyen de ministère un sujet la
diversification agricole on augmente
bien
avec nos petits crédits qui passent de
3,6 mais c'est doublé des crédits du
ministère de l'Agriculture qui sont à 45
et ceux du possible qui sont à 45 donc
il nous faut commencer à travailler le
nouveau système pour le 1er janvier 2024
là aussi bonjour Bruxelles on ira
souvent
nous viendrons également soutien des
entreprises mises en difficulté par la
des coûts de l'énergie 10 millions et de
prévu à ce titre l'an prochain on
travaille à la mise en œuvre création de
valeur je voudrais insister sur la
prolongation de la défiscalisation
jusqu'en 2029 qui a été décidée pour
tous les dispositifs et tous les
territoires c'est un geste fort que vous
avez été nombreux à demander pour donner
de la visibilité aux investisseurs
maintenant que cette visibilité donnée
est importante de toute façon avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal travaille
d'évaluation sur son investissement
productif dans la
perspective du PLF 2024 troisième
priorité l'ambition républicaine c'est
la sécurité publique je perds venir ici
la loi je l'ai dit ce matin la loi
immigration aussi participera c'est pas
assimiler tout ça mais je veux dire il y
a trop de gens qui n'ont pas de boulot
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça et qui
vole
pour aller manger
les moyens mais je vais insister sur les
moyens de service militaire adaptés
augmenter 30 millions d'euros
c'est bien accueillir davantage de
volontaires renforcer leur compétences
leurs qualifications j'ai une idée mes
je suis loin d'avoir gagné c'est
compliqué il faut que je redéploie c'est
Saint-Martin vous le savez là aussi on
en a parlé ensemble quatrième priorité
l'accompagnement des collectivités
locales territoriales les moyens de mon
ministère qui sont dédiés passeront de
205 millions à 270 millions d'euros en
2023 soit plus 32%
le maire de mon village à Langogne il en
revient pas il alors certes il y a du
retard enfin Langogne c'est pas non plus
Abu Dhabi
c'est une progression considérable
que nous avons fortement défendu avec
Gérald Darmanin
et je pense qu'on a bien fait les moyens
des forums créer un initiative du
sénateur patient que je salue député
Castle sont augmentés 30 millions dont
20 millions CV séchés pour lui sméag le
fond outremer sera bondé à hauteur de 10
millions enfin de poursuit les
financements des assistances techniques
là-dessus je voulais vous dire que j'ai
un projet que je travaille avec la
Banque Postale et avec
l'AFD c'est d'avoir des pôles
d'assistance technique déjà installés
et qui seront saisis librement par les
collectivités qui est à chaque fois une
demande qui est pas chaque fois
d'interrogation il veut une assistance
technique elle est là elle est prête
j'espère
avoir l'accord du ministère des Affaires
étrangères qui dit mais non le FDC c'est
pour nous c'est pas pour toi donc on va
essayer de se battre et je pense que
nous l'aurons les moyens du fond
exceptionnel FEI ont été stabilisés à
110 millions et je suis heureux de dire
que j'ai le pouvoir désormais de fixer
le taux de subvention à 100%. avant
c'était à 80% et donc je pense que c'est
bien
on va y arriver
j'essaie d'accélérer un mot sur les
finances locales
[Musique]
réjouissons-nous
réjouissons-nous ensemble il y a pas de
mal à se faire du bien du rattrapage de
conformément l'engagement du président
de la République depuis ce depuis 2016
se rattrapage s'élève à 150 millions
d'euros les collectivités ultramarines
profiteront aussi de la progression
nationale de la dotation globale de 300
millions
du côté investissement la création du
fond vert doté de 2 milliards d'euros et
pour moi une caravane chargée d'or qui
passe et on va essayer au profit de
l'outre-mer d'y arriver je serai là pour
aider les collectivités
ultramarines à essayer d'avoir ce
dispositif elle déployée contre la vie
chère juste un mot et puis je vais
m'arrêter
ça sera présenté le 8 décembre
c'est fait c'est fort je veux pas le
dire avant mais moi je pense que nous
aurons tous une bonne surprise on va
mettre ensemble tout ce qui se fait et
je pense que nous aurons une bonne
surprise toujours en lien avec cette
démarche la première partie du PLF
on doit citer le sénateur Théophile on a
réussi sa vie quand on est passé de la
on a passé à la poste l'importation des
paquets des douanes à la poste ça a été
gigantesque pendant tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont appliqué la loi qui
n'était pas appliquées avant ils ont pas
fait des choses imbéciles ils ont
appliqué la loi
ce qui ne s'était pas fait avant ça fait
bondir les prix j'ai donc obtenu je
pense l'augmentation à 400 euros de la
franchise de taxation pour les envois de
colis non commerciaux qui étaient
auparavant à 200 à 205 si fort quand
même
l'octroi de mer et j'en terminerai là
que le premier a permis aux
collectivités locales région comme
commune de passer la crise financière
pas tout à fait à l'aise mais
correctement la l'octroie de mer est un
et d'un dynamisme que personne ne veut
reconnaître nous allons le changer mais
nous allons le changer ensemble en
mettant trois focus
une recette des collectivités locales
quatre focus les recettes des
collectivités locales la défense de
l'emploi local la défense de l'écologie
et du climat tout ça
en lisant avec l'ensemble de la
fiscalité que se passera-t-il lorsqu'il
y a plus de la fiscalité sur l'essence
puisqu'on fera plus d'essence il faut
bien inventer quelque chose donc on va
réinventer l'octroi de mer au milieu de
la fiscalité je m'arrête c'est compliqué
en 10 minutes mais
c'est passionnant et je continuais avec
vous merci
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance pour quelques instants elle sera
reprise à 17h20
[Musique]
ministre pour l'amendement 961 c'est à
VOUS
original mais je suis pas un spécialiste
c'est un amendement qui vous demande
le lever le gage des amendements adopté
à l'Assemblée nationale pour les 53
millions d'euros
donc on discutera vos amendements ils se
mettent d'accord j'espère sur un certain
nombre d'entre eux je souhaite que
on puisse régulariser l'émission les
montants de la mission outre-mer tel que
voter par tel qu'ils ont été repris pour
ceux qui ont été repris par la première
ministre suite au vote de l'Assemblée
nationale
53 millions est dégagés au niveau de la
mission en fin de concrétiser cette
hausse des moyens il était il est
nécessaire de lever le gage sur ces
amendements
et c'est l'objet de celui-ci cet
amendement supré également les deux
programmes créés par amendement
parlementaire centre d'examen des
concours de la fonction publique dans
chaque collectivité ultra-marine et
extension du passeport mobilité aux
personnes engagées dans le dispositif de
validation des acquis et rapatriés ces
programmes qui étaient dotés de 1
million chacun on crée pas un programme
spécial on ira pas rapatrice on crée des
missions des programmes pour un million
d'euros je crois que l'administration va
être un peu envahissante c'est ce que je
ne souhaite pas donc je vous demande de
lever le gage des amendements adoptés à
l'Assemblée nationale pour 53 millions
d'euros
quelle est la vie de la commission
pardon il y a une discussion comme une
monsieur le rapporteur je excusez-moi
monsieur patient j'ai d'autres
amendements à présenter c'est Madame
jasmin avant
et complémentaire à celui de Monsieur le
Ministre parce qu'en fait la Cour des
comptes a fait un rapport récent qui
remet en cause le fonctionnement
justement de l'atome de la mission
ministérielle à l'égalité des chances et
là
les crédits qui sont mentionnés
justement et adopter probablement
doivent être utilisés mais pas de façon
redondante avec plus de transparence de
plus déficience et en ce moment nous
avons un mille-feuille administratif qui
pénalise à la fois les décideurs publics
mais aussi les citoyens donc on a
maintenant permis de clarifier dans les
différents domaines de compétence de
chacun et d'avoir plus de transparence
d'obtenir une traçabilité une lisibilité
et de pouvoir évaluer l'utilisation de
ces fonds qui seront probablement
utilisés et peut-être que vous allez
voter l'amendement de Monsieur le
Ministre pour lequel concernant le gage
en tout cas il s'agira d'évaluer et de
mettre en place des prérequis pour une
planification pluriannuelle afin de
mieux répondre aux besoins des
collectivités de nos concitoyens des
Outre-mer en toute transparence merci
merci Madame coco
la cuisse de l'aérien est totalement
d'actualité vous savez lorsqu'on l'on
vit dans ces pays aller faire des études
aller se soigner aller tout simplement
rejoindre sa famille des familles qui
sont souvent éclatées à cause de
mutations
complexe et bien il faut qu'on avion
il faut prendre l'avion et prendre
l'avion ça coûte cher en ce moment un
sablier bi en économique pour la
Martinique peut toucher jusqu'à 2000
euros pour un aller-retour vous voyez
bien comment des populations sont
exclues de ces voyages qu'il s'agisse de
population qui ont déjà les difficultés
publiques fragiles mais également les
classes moyennes
donc une grande partie de la population
donc mon amendement est pour demander
qu'il y a 30 millions de portées vous
savez ça n'a rien d'original la cause
dispose de moyens financiers importants
qui sont mis par le gouvernement pour
permettre cette continuité territoriale
la Corse dispose de moyenne et pas
autant mis par le gouvernement et
pourtant la Corse est à 1h30 de Paris
donc on a il faut absolument là aussi
afficher une attention donc je demande
qu'il est 30 millions qui soient fléchés
pour permettre une meilleure mobilité de
nos populations je rappelle que ce
déplacer c'est souvent pour se soigner
pas pris en charge par la Sécurité
Sociale quand il faut parfois attendre 7
8 9 mois pour avoir un rendez-vous avec
les spécialistes qui font cruellement
des faux chez nous nous sommes des
déserts médicaux à ciel ouvert
merci Madame Jacques pour le 252
c'est amendement en amplifier les forts
budgétaires initiés lors des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque le
gouvernement avait consenti à conserver
un abonnement abondant le 5 millions
d'euros les crédits du programme 123
conditions de vie outre-mer pour
accroître les moyens dédiées à la
continuité territoriale pour l'année
2022 l'Agence pour la mobilité estime
l'augmentation du prix des billets
d'avion environ 23 % ce qui la conduit à
puiser dans sa trésorerie dans ce
contexte il part indispensable de donner
les moyens à la Dom de remplir
effectivement ces missions qui relèvent
de l'unité de la République et de la
solidarité vis-à-vis des citoyens
ultramarins cet amendement vise tout
particulièrement interpellé le ministre
en charge des outre-mer pour qu'il
confirme l'engagement pris à l'Assemblée
nationale et s'engage à actualiser au
plus vite l'arrêter fixant les montants
des divers aides liés à la continuité
territoriale afin de respecter les aides
de recevabilité budgétaire cet
amendement prélève un million d'euros en
autorisation de paiement et de paiement
sur le programme 138 pour abonder le
programme 123 de la mission première je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Madame
Petrus pour le 769 monsieur le ministre
monsieur collègue c'est amendement a
pour objet d'abonner de 350 000 € les
crédits consacrés à la continuité
territoriale afin de permettre une prise
en charge des frais de transport et des
indemnités forfaitaires journalières
d'hébergement des malades résidant sur
le territoire de Saint-Martin et devant
se rendre Swan Guadeloupe ou Martinique
ou encore plus loin un hexagone pour y
être soigné sur place faute de structure
ou de spécialiste sur le territoire il
m'apparaît nécessaire de rappeler
l'importance du volley santé de l'aide à
la continuité territoriale au sein du
budget de la mission outre-mer pour 2023
les crédits consacrés à la continuité
territoriale ne permettent pas de
prendre en charge ses frais qui sont
pourtant élevés pour des ultramarins qui
la plupart du temps doivent financer ses
déplacements à partir de leur budget
personnel afin de leur éviter une
rupture ou une perte de chance dans en
cours de soins en effet sur le
territoire de Saint-Martin nous n'avons
pas de chirurgien vasculaire par le
chirurgie plastique de reconstruction
pas de neurochirurgie pas de chirurgie
cardiaque au niveau des spécialités
médicales il manque un spécialiste en
neurologie ou en rhumatologie pas de
pneumologue pas de chirurgien spécialisé
de l'épaule etc autant de médecins qui
ne sont pas présents ou qui ne viennent
plus pour ceux qui faisaient le
déplacement car le coût du billet
d'avion en constante augmente à Sion les
en aura définitivement dissuadés il en
est le même pour les patients qui ne
peuvent pas se rendre en Martinique en
Guadeloupe ou en France hexagonale à
cause du coût du transport les fonds
continuité territoriale doit donc
pouvoir prendre en charge sans condition
de ressources le titre de transport
entre les collectivités de résidence
outre-mer et l'Hexagone dans le cas où
la santé du patiente nécessite et si par
cet amendement je souhaite que l'État
puisse accompagner ses dépenses et des
malades et de leur accompagnateurs très
souvent aux revenus modestes et ainsi
mettre en place cette couverture
supplémentaire afin de favoriser la
santé publique je vous remercie merci
merci
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
de même inspiration en réalité ça
concerne Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et ça
vise abandonné de 100.000 euros les
crédits consacrés à la continuité
territoriale pour permettre une prise en
charge des frais de transport et
indemnités forfaitaire journalière
d'hébergement des accompagnateurs
successives en activité qui réside à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et qui doivent
accompagner des malades dans l'Hexagone
qui viennent pour trois à quatre
semaines voire beaucoup plus pour les
traitements médicaux à l'heure actuelle
la Caisse de Prévoyance Sociale et cet
amendement est travaillé en concertation
avec la Caisse locale ne prend en charge
que le prix de la campagne billet
d'avion de la campagnateur initiale et
pas successif or on peut évidemment
imaginer que ces accompagnateurs ont une
activité professionnelle et doivent
revenir à un moment donné sur le
territoire laissant le malade évidemment
seul dans l'Hexagone dans ce budget donc
les crédits de la mission outre-mer pour
2023 la stagnation des crédits consacré
à la continuité ne permet pas de prendre
en charge ses frais qui ne sont pas
actuellement prévus dans le dispositif
de la Caisse de Prévoyance sociale c'est
la seule manière que nous avons trouvé
pour pouvoir assurer cette prise en
charge d'une certaine équité et une
certaine humanité dont la prise en
charge des gens et permettent notamment
aux accompagnateurs pour des traitements
longs et les suivis médicaux très longs
dans l'Hexagone à plus de 5000 km
merci Monsieur patient quelle est la vie
de la Commission sur ses amendements
alors je vais
répondre dans la commission des finances
à l'amendement de monsieur le ministre
c'est un moment du gouvernement vise à
ouvrir les crédits nécessaires à la
suite des mesures adoptées à l'Assemblée
nationale nous n'avons aucune difficulté
sur le montant total mais nous nous
interrogeons sur un point particulier
pourquoi les 2 millions des programmes
supprimés sont portés sur le programme
138 alors que l'objet de ces 2 millions
était clairement orienté sur des
problématiques continuités territoriales
et donc sur l'action 3 du programme 123
nous souhaiterions une explication sur
ce point mais la vie sera bien entendu
favorable
je prends le relais donc sur les trois
amendements suivants celui de Madame
jasmin dans cet amendement qui prévoit
la majoration de 1 million d'euros des
crédits à louer à la continuité
territoriale mais surtout ils prévoient
la création d'un nouveau programme pour
suivre cette politique et avoir une
vision d'ensemble des problématiques
liées à ce sujet alors nous comprenons
l'attention bien entendu toutefois la
création d'un nouveau programme ne nous
paraît pas une solution pour améliorer
le suivi la gestion des crédits dédié à
la continuité ou même mettre en place
une stratégie globale par ailleurs la
création d'un nouveau programme
budgétaire s'accompagne de contraintes
logistiques importantes que soulever
d'ailleurs le ministre tout à l'heure
avec la désignation des responsable de
programme la création de nouveaux
budgets opérationnels de programme bop
et nouvelle unités opérationnelles
est-ce que celui de la politique de
continuité territoriale doit être
confiée à la DOM
ou à une autre structure cette question
doit également être posée aussi d'après
nos informations la délégation
aux autres mers c'est notre maire
devrait mener une mission d'information
sur la continuité territoriale dès
l'année prochaine dans ce contexte s'il
nous paraît raisonnable d'attente ses
conclusions et recommandations donc dans
la tente la commission des finances
demande le retrait de cet amendement
pour ce qui est l'amendement de Madame
Concorde donc à l'issue des travaux
menés à l'Assemblée nationale
les crédits à louer à la continuité
territoriale ont été majorées 5 millions
d'euros afin de garantir réellement le
principe de continuité territoriale dans
un contexte inflationniste que vous avez
évoqué qui se caractérise par une hausse
des prix des billets d'avion entre la
métropole et le territoire d'outre-mer
dans environ 20% sur un an il semble que
cette augmentation de plus de 10% des
crédits dédiés à la continuité
territoriale soit déjà de nature à
répondre aux attendus des billets
d'avion de surcroît contrairement à
d'autres actions les crédits de l'action
3 du programme 123 sont demain manière
régulière sous consommée
et nous ne faisons je ne fais pas
référence là aux années 2020 et 2021
marquée par la crise sanitaire qui ont
de fait vu les vols entre la métropole
et les outre-mer diminuaient fortement
en 2018 on a eu 39,4 millions d'euros
ont été consommés pour 41,1 millions
d'euros ouverts en LFI soit 2000 mois et
en 2019 35,5 millions d'euros ont été
consommés pour 42,1 million d'euros
d'ouverture soit près de 7 millions
d'euros en CP également nous constatons
également une sous-consommation pardon
2018 et 2019 comprise entre 1 et 2
millions d'euros soit l'équivalent de ce
qui est demandé dans le présent
amendement par ailleurs l'aide
d'exceptionnels à la Corse que vous avez
à juste titre évoqué votez lors de la
loi de finances rectificative pour 2022
m'a concerné non pas les billets d'avion
mais la D7 maritime dans le cas de la
délégation de service public donc ce
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes sujets
nous restons vigilants avec vous bien
entendu à la hausse des prix des billets
d'avion et à la consommation de crédit
dédié à la continuité territoriale et
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas recommandé
une majoration en 2024 ou avant si le
contexte le justifie donc c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission et c'est
pour les mêmes raisons à la vie
défavorable pour le moment présenté par
Madame Jacques
monsieur le ministre non pour la suite
des amandes non pardon
l'amendement de Madame Petrus vise un
majoré de 350 000 euros les crédits du
programme 123
afin de financer la prise en charge du
transport et des indemnités forfaitaires
journalières d'hébergement des personnes
malades
présidents dans les territoires de
Saint-Barthélemy et Saint-Martin et
devant se rendre soit en Guadeloupe ou
Martinique ou dans l'Hexagone
cette question est particulièrement
sensible qu'elle touche les malades ou
les personnes les accompagnant
par ailleurs elle n'est pas limitée à un
ou quelques territoires il faut me
sentir cesser de prendre le problème
territoire par territoire mais il nous
faut avoir une approche globale de ce
sujet pour tous les territoires
ultramarins dans lesquels Louvre de
soins n'est pas aussi complète qu'en
métropole ce problème mérite donc un
traitement qui va au-delà de
Saint-Martin et de Saint-Barthélemy
c'est pourquoi je mettrai un avis
défavorable mais j'invite le
gouvernement et les ministres concernés
par cette question sensible organisée
rapidement une réflexion qui permettra
d'accompagner au mieux les malades et
leurs accompagnants qui doivent se
rendre en métropole pour raison médicale
pour l'amendement de Monsieur arsano la
commission des finances a émis le même
avis
c'est un problème qui mérite un
traitement qui va au-delà de
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon l'appareil
aussi une invitation au gouvernement et
au ministre concerné par cette question
sensible à organiser rapidement une
réflexion
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente pour répondre
au sénateur patient d'abord sur le lever
du gaz mais services me confirme
puisqu'il s'agit de programmes dédié
qui relève de l'information et concours
c'est bien sur le programme 138
dans un spécialiste mais je saurais pas
moi vous répondre je fais confiance à
mes services qui me disent que c'est
bien sur le 138
sur l'ensemble des amendements
continuité territoriales c'est un vrai
sujet il y a la continuité territoriale
d'une part et la double continuité
comment on fait pour aller sujet qui
marche bien donc je peux le signaler
pour aller de
Pointe-à-Pitre au centre ça marche
mais il y a plein de choses qui marchent
pas j'ajoute que dans cette continuité
territoriale vous avez le bateau qu'il
faut pas oublier le transport maritime
et le transport aérien pour répondre à
la demande de Madame Conques je crois si
vous faites un programme spécial je
pense que on va y perdre de l'argent je
me mets de votre côté
non c'est Madame jasmin
[Musique]
spécifique
continuité territoriale
si on le met je pense que les
territoires ultramarins ils perdront
puisque tous ceux qui participent diront
c'est pas nous c'est vous la continuité
territoriale c'est le ministère des
Transports
ces mystères des finances surtout et le
ministère en charge des Outre-mer je
rappelle que mon premier sujet sur la
continuité territoriale madame dendar en
est témoin c'est bien d'avoir des
compagnies aériennes
ça me coûte ça coûte à l'état 150
millions à la Réunion ça va
coûter à peu près la même chose pour le
premier coup à tirer
dans les Antilles et peut-être 50
derrière sans parler d'erguyan qui va
pas bien vous falloir mettre quand même
quelques argent
je pense que si on est sur une
seule mission on n'aura pas les
financements extérieurs j'ajoute que un
problème du aérien j'ai effectivement la
Guyane et puis il y a la liaison entre
Wallis et Futuna où nos amis d'aircalins
ont dit gentiment mais on y va pas
j'essaye d'appeler Air Tahiti aussi
[Musique]
président friche pour dire quand même
fait un petit effort donc il y a tout ce
problème d'abord de compagnie aérienne
sur les problèmes de compagnie maritime
le sujet sur les rien j'ajoute qu'on
travaille sur Saint-Martin avec Air
Caraïbes pour qu'il reprenne ce qui
s'était fait avant et sur
Saint-Barthélémy j'ai pas au lit
il est là
on reporte d'un an pour travailler
on report d'un an pour travailler à
améliorer
la délégation de service public avec
Air Saint-Pierre qui lui-même la sub
délègue avec une autre compagnie donc on
va essayer de refonder un peu ça en
maintenant ce qui est là pour cette
année tout ça sera évidemment dans les
contrats de convergence et de
j'appelle les contrats de plan de 2024
et puis donc d'abord les compagnies sur
les prix je travaille j'ai une rencontre
je pense que c'est demain
lundi ou mardi avec la présidente d'Air
France et son directeur général ils
viennent me voir tous les deux j'ai un
coup de fil cet après-midi ce soir avec
le président du Breuil pour leur
demander un petit effort
j'espère que dans le j'ai pas gagné mais
j'espère que dans le
ou Dino du pouvoir d'achat on pourra
annoncer quelques sujets aériens sur la
continuité territoriale j'ajoute que
c'est aussi le transport des conteneurs
sur lesquels on travaille tout ça est un
vaste sujet je pense que de réduire une
une mission gérée par la rue ou Dino on
va y perdre beaucoup on va y perdre
beaucoup
deuxième sujet plus particulier la Dom
la Dom ça fait 6 mois qui a puni
président ni directeur à peu près je
crois et donc il y a plus de politique
on en fait une
une agence de tickets de voyage donc il
nous faut refonder cette politique je
réunirai les élus pour refonder cette
politique puisque les deux responsables
sont désormais désignés l'un est nommé
il a été élu à l'unanimité et l'autre
est désigné au moins dans la tête de
Gérald Darmanin et la mienne donc il
reste plus qu'à signer le papier et on
l'a rencontré et il nous semble faire
l'affaire on va donc avec d'ores et déjà
7 millions de plus sur la Dom par
rapport à 2022 puisqu'on avait 45 et on
ajoute 7 ça fait 15% ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est pas négligeable 15% de
plus sachant qu'on n'a pas de vrai
politique donc essayons de faire un peu
de politique de transport à qui on veut
le donner pour qui on le fait au profit
de qui et on va y arriver
donc pour toutes ces raisons
pour faire un geste pour dire que vous
avez raison mais parce que c'est pas
tout à fait le moment de le faire qu'on
a tellement de choses à faire j'ai au
nom du gouvernement je donnerai un avis
défavorable à l'amendement de Madame
jasmin un avis défavorable à
l'amendement de Madame foncone par
contre un avis favorable à l'amendement
de Madame Jacques parce que ces
symbolique parce que c'est symbolique de
dire oui on va continuer pas le moment
d'aller plus loin mais de manière
symbolique j'ai envie de vous dire on
continue et un amendement défavorable
nous avons de Monsieur Artano une madame
Pétrus parce que je crois qu'il faut
aussi il ne faut pas que sur ce budget
de la continuité territoriale on se
remplace de la Sécu
imaginez que si on fait ça
la sécu nous dira mais chutes
d'outre-mer vous vous débrouillez
puisque vous voulez y aller donc
essayons on revient à cette mission ce
programme spécifique c'est tellement
vaste que on le voit bien dans le
programme LBU c'est ce qui nous mène à
c'est que on revienne sur la
défiscalisation dans le logement et on
dit c'est dans la mission mais dans quoi
si on fait ça dans trois ans que
restera-t-il on va nous serrer donc je
pense qu'il faut éviter de réduire les
programmes et puis il faut éviter je
suis désolé de dire ça pour nos amis
Saint-Martin et de Saint-Pierre
évitons d'avoir des sur le problème de
la continuité territoriale évitons de le
faire territoire par territoire ayant
cette vue d'ensemble ayant cette vue
d'ensemble avant d'agir sur la
continuité territoriale j'ai le problème
maritime chez vous je pense qu'on y
travaille sur le port c'est réglé
puisqu'on sait ce qu'on veut faire et
sur l'aérien il est il est prolongé d'un
an je réunirai parce que c'est un vrai
sujet vous avez raison je pense je vais
écrire aux deux présidents des
délégations
ultramarines du Parlement pour leur dire
on se fait une réunion globale de
politique avec le ministre des
Transports faire ça début janvier voilà
madame la Présidente la position du
gouvernement sur les amendements un qui
est favorable
parce qu'il est moins cher mais il est
symbolique les autres défavorables sur
toute
merci Madame merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je vous ai entendu
je suis prêt à enlever mon amendement
mais je voudrais quand même que les
recommandations de la Cour des comptes
concernant la traçabilité la
transparente la clarté soit prise en
compte parce que on ne peut pas non plus
continuer c'est de l'argent public mal
utilisé pas utilisé on ne sait plus donc
c'est voir comment d'autre part vous
avez parlé de la sécurité sociale
monsieur le ministre nous avons eu
examiner les
le budget de la Sécurité sociale le
PLFSS et bien les coefficients
géographiques c'est un sujet et les
évacuations sanitaires c'est encore un
sujet et ici même on ne vote jamais ça
quel que soit les banques et là le
budget de la Sécurité sociale c'est
aussi une dans nos préoccupations donc
moi je suis prête à enlever j'enlève
d'ailleurs madame la Présidente mais je
dis qu'il faut à un moment donné la
transparence tant mieux compte de la
Cour des comptes pour mieux faire
[Musique]
oui j'ai entendu les avis des rapports
et de Monsieur le Ministre alors la
cause ça s'explique parce que il y a le
bateau
donc il faut du bateau pour avoir plus
d'argent je rappelle que pour prendre le
bateau sortir de cours si quelques
heures faire une transatlantique c'est
8h c'est 8 jours pardon il y a pas de
navire transportant du des passagers
donc on n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes
considérations il faut envisager cette
question sur la mobilité la plus juste
et la plus équitable dans la République
que l'on soit sur dans les pays de la
dite outre-mer ou que l'on soit en Corse
qui est aussi outre-mer la cause soyons
logique et que l'on soit sur le
territoire hexagonal il faut une
politique équitable aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un est malade et qu'il doit se
rendre en France pour se faire soigner
parce qu'il est dans ce désert médical
et qu'il ne peut pas attendre trois mois
que la sécurité sociale lui réponde pour
une prise en charge il est obligé de
partir et ça lui coûte entre 1000 et
2000 euros on voit l'économique
c'est ça la réalité donc il y a une
rupture d'égalité à la fois dans les
soins et une rupture d'égalité à la fois
dans la mobilité alors Monsieur le
Ministre sachez que le président altano
accédé à ma demande de mission sur la
continuité territoriale on commencera
tabour battant avec mon collègue
chevrolier dans les premiers jours de
janvier on ira vite rassurez-vous et
donc j'espère que dès la fin du premier
trimestre vous serez toutes oui à nos
recommandations merci Monsieur théophile
oui madame la Présidente permettez-moi
de rebondir sur les propos de notre
collègue Concorde sur la hausse des prix
d'une manière générale les billets
d'avion
vous savez que le baromètre du transport
aérien précisait qu'au départ de
l'ensemble des départements d'outre-mer
l'augmentation des prix des billets
d'avion atteignait
32,40 % au mois d'octobre 2022 + 19,2%
reculent cette tendance touche les
quatre départements de manière
différenciée la Guadeloupe que je
connais mieux affichant le plus fort la
plus forte hausse soit 37,2%
le ministre que Monsieur le Ministre
j'avais également alerté la première
ministre sur le sujet mais nous devons
réfléchir collectivement à ce sujet nous
n'avons pas d'avion à illogène pour
l'instant et nous ne demandons pas de
subventionner bien sûr le kérosène mais
nous devons tout de même vérifier
l'existence d'une éventuelle
probablement il se pourrait que d'une
éventuelle entente entre les compagnies
sur les prix pratiqués et je reçois avec
satisfaction la discussion dans le cadre
du du ou Dino de la vie chère c'est très
bien de pouvoir le faire pour mieux
éclaircir la situation et nous donner
des visibilité là-dessus
oui merci simplement peut-être décevoir
monsieur le ministre mais l'article
l18031 du code des transports prévoit
que la politique de continuité
territoriale tente atténuer les
contraintes de l'insularité et de
l'éloignement et à rapprocher des
conditions d'accès de la population au
service public de transport de formation
et de santé je n'y suis pour rien c'est
législatif donc effectivement tout le
monde a entendu que le ministère
d'outre-mer ne voulait pas aller sur le
volet santé je suis surpris il faut
savoir qu'à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
c'est le décret du 25 mars 91 qui
prévoit que la Caisse de Prévoyance
Sociale monsieur le ministre donc la
CNAM la sécurité sociale organise cette
prise en charge un second accompagnateur
peut bénéficier d'une indemnité
journalière mais certainement pas d'une
prise en charge de son billet ni le
troisième accompagnateur donc je demande
simplement parce que c'est le seul
levier que j'ai aujourd'hui de pouvoir
trouver un dispositif tampon et si vous
voulez que la sécurité sociale prenne le
relais dans un an et j'ai très envie de
vous dire dans deux ans ou dans trois
ans quand on connaît l'inertie de
l'administration sur ces sujets en ce
qui concerne Saint-Pierre en particulier
moi de le dire à tous les ventes de
cette hémicycle je pense qu'on doit
prendre cette mesure qui ne coûtera pas
dans le budget de l'État concernant une
population de 6000 habitants voilà il
faut quand même ramener les choses à ce
qu'elles sont également c'est un geste
d'humanité de solidarité on fera le
bilan et si la sécurité sociale veut
prendre le relais et je l'espère
également monsieur le ministre mais
aujourd'hui dans le temps qui m'est
donné dans le temps qui nous est donné
nous n'avons pas d'autres dispositifs
relais
bien monsieur le ministre j'ai entendu
vos arguments et j'ai compris vos
arguments ne saurait faire de la
continuité territoriale une histoire de
territoire néanmoins sur le territoire
de Saint-Martin nous n'avons pas de Chu
nous n'avons pas de centre hospitalier
universitaire et tous les autres
territoires qui sont autour de moi de
mon territoire c'est justement sur ces
territoires là que nous allons ils n'ont
pas du tout ma problématique ils ont des
spécialistes par nombre en grand nombre
mais ils en ont moi j'ai posé la
question au directeur de l'ARS
concernant le le chirurgien vasculaire
et lui il m'a dit qu'en Guadeloupe il y
en a qu'un seul mais au moins il y en a
un en Guadeloupe chez nous il y en a pas
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai posé cette
amendement spécifique pour Saint-Martin
parce que justement nous n'avons pas du
tout la même problématique que la
Guadeloupe la Martinique ou la Guyane
donc je maintiens l'amendement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre c'est bien là la difficulté
vous avez raison de rappeler qu'il y a
la continuité territoriale sauf que dans
le code il est précisé que la continuité
s'applique à la santé et souvent quand
on rencontre les ministères on nous on
nous a dit l'enveloppe a été
sous-utilisée principalement même sur
les rapatriements
des défunts ou des corps sur l'enveloppe
la réalité c'est que dans l'urgence
quand quelqu'un meurt ou quelqu'un a un
problème de santé il ne peut pas
s'adresser à la DOM ou au service de
l'État pour obtenir très rapidement un
billet d'avion
l'accompagnement des malades est assurée
par la Sécurité sociale qui prend en
charge le billet d'avion du malade et
d'un accompagnement de parents ou d'un
médecin quand cette personne a besoin
d'être accompagnée par un médecin à la
réunion nous avons mis en place via la
collectivité départementale
une modalité d'accompagnement des
malades et je comprends bien ce que
Madame petrice dit pour son territoire
et mon collègue Artano puisque quand il
n'y a pas de possibilité de prise en
charge direct il faudrait que la
collectivité soit remboursée sur les
dépenses qu'elle pourrait faire pour
accompagner les malades et mais vous
avez bien raison il y a la continuité
territoriale et l'égalité de traitement
vis-à-vis de la santé de tous les
citoyens de la République et donc je
crois que ce que propose en tous les cas
sur le territoire de Saint-Pierre et
Miquelon et de Saint-Martin je crois
qu'il faut trouver une solution ne
serait-ce que une enveloppe de
remboursement puisque cette enveloppe
est sous-utilisée dans le cadre de la
continuité
merci
avant que nous procédions au vote
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
préciser que sur l'amendement de Madame
Jacques vous levez le gage
sur l'ensemble de ces amendements moi je
dis que c'est pas absurde c'est pas mais
je suis défavorable à l'idée qu'on prend
les problèmes un par un avant d'avoir
réfléchi ensemble avant je précise ma
pensée je suis favorable avec ce que
j'organiserai à une réunion que
j'organiserai avec les parlementaires
des deux délégations avec le ministère
des Transports pour voir ce qui se passe
je suis favorable à l'idée que la Dom
est enfin une politique ça fait si au
moins 6 mois qu'elle en a pas avec avec
15% de crédit supplémentaires s'agissant
du petit problème de petit en volume de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon perdu on est
toujours croissance combien de milliers
d'euros c'est
c'est minuscule donc la Dom peut le
faire si on décide mais la dame ne
décidera essayons de pas faire des
régimes partout des trucs on y comprend
plus rien essayons d'avoir cette
politique c'est donc
au motif de cette unicité de politique
au motif de cette volonté de travailler
avec la Dom au motif de l'argent
gigantesque qu'on met ça va être près de
500 millions quand même cette année avec
les compagnies au motif de mon espoir de
bien travailler avec les compagnies
aériennes que je maintiens la vie que
j'ai donné sur ces divers amendements en
espérant que chacun puisse les retirer
au vu d'une dans la perspective d'un
règlement global de ce sujet monsieur le
ministre pour le gage
non pas sur le gage vous levez non non
sur le gage sur ses amendements
amendement vous avez donné un avis
favorable à l'amendement de Madame
Jacques c'est à dire que le gouvernement
est d'accord avec l'amendement mais
c'est amendement est gagé la dépense
engagée et il faudrait que vous leviez
le gage il faudrait
on a quand même
je veux dire on consomme pas les sous la
vérité c'est qu'on consomme pas les sous
c'est les bras vous le savez bien on a
un problème j'ai dit j'espère pouvoir
venir on ne consomme pas les crédits de
l'émission outre-mer donc un peu ça
suffit à la fin donc voilà moi je veux
bien si on me consomme tout on fait
lever le gâche sinon il y a des moyens
de le faire
très bien
on va donc procéder au vote d'abord
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui est un
avis favorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstein était adopté
celui de la même jasmin est retirée
madame cancone retirez également madame
Jacques avis défavorable de la
commission et favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre qui est adopté
c'est double avis défavorable qui est
pour
quiconque qui s'abstient il est adopté
le 394 de Monsieur Artano double avis
défavorable également qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est
également adopté
[Musique]
qui défend madame billon c'est vous qui
défendez 757
oui merci madame la Présidente donc cet
amendement de notre collègue Lana
tétouani propose de retirer 42 millions
d'euros sur l'action 2 aide à
l'insertion et à la qualification de 138
emploie outre-mer afin de les redéployer
à l'action 4 sanitaire social culture
Jeunesse et Sport du programme 123 il
s'agit d'un appel à la solidarité
nationale la gestion de la caisse de
prévoyance sociale CPS de la Polynésie a
évolué dans le temps mais suite à
l'arrêt des essais nucléaires et
l'instabilité politique il était
impératif de réformer ses régimes pour
une adaptation aux nouvelles exigences
économiques démographiques de la santé
publique la population est de plus en
plus vieillissante en Polynésie avec de
graves pathologies dont le coût de
gestion est extrêmement onéreux pour une
petite collectivité comme ce pays cette
Polynésie les charges liées aux maladies
radio intuites liées aux essais
nucléaires des ressortissants de la CPS
Aubert gravement le régime maladie de
notre caisse l'impact financier a été le
régime maladie de notre caisse l'impact
financier a été évaluée à plus de 47
millions d'euros par an sur les 5
dernières années de 2014 à 2018 et ses
charges ne font pas l'objet de
compensation par l'État la Polynésie
avait bénéficié de l'accompagnement de
l'État dans les années 2015-2020 dans le
cadre d'une convention solidarité signée
entre l'État et le pays depuis des
réformes essentiels ont été engagés
localement pour une meilleure
gouvernance de la CPS et par la mise en
place d'une nouvelle TVA sociale afin
d'assurer l'équilibre financier des
différents régimes de prestations
sociales mais la pandémie en 2020
donnait un coup d'arrêt brutal à toute
notre toute l'économie insulaire mettant
en péril notre système de protection
sociale donc c'est l'objet de cet
amendement que j'ai tenté de défendre
aussi bien que d'autres collègues lanaté
Tony du groupe Union centriste l'aurait
défendu je vous remercie
merci quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur cet amendement
oui merci madame la Présidente ma
collègue madame tétouanouie n'est pas là
mais je répondrai à Madame billon
effectivement
c'est un amendement visa majoritaire 42
millions d'euros les crédits du
programme 123 afin de financer le régime
de solidarité de la Polynésie française
vous l'avez rappelé c'est un amendement
d'appel
qui est formulé donc pour mémoire suite
à l'achèvement en 2020 de la
contribution financière au régime de
solidarité de la Polynésie française de
12 millions d'euros par an le choix du
gouvernement polynésien auquel j'ai
appartenu dans une autre vie a été de
s'orienter vers une convention globale
de santé 2021 2023 qui était signé le 14
octobre 2021 entre l'État et le pays
d'ailleurs les crédits je l'ai souligné
dans la discussion générale ont été
inscrits cette année ainsi après avoir
contribué à l'équilibre du régime
solidarité de 93 à 2007 puis 2015 à 2020
et permis ainsi aux populations fragiles
de bénéficier d'une protection sociale
l'État à la demande du pays
orienté avec cette nouvelle convention
globale de santé son soutien vers
l'amélioration de la prise en charge des
patients en favorisant l'accès et la
qualité de l'offre de soins à nos
populations des îles éloignées notamment
et puis le traitement de l'oncologie et
du cancer
il est prévu à ce style 4 millions
d'euros par an je le soulignais dans la
discussion générale donc c'est
amendement vise à mettre en place une
nouvelle convention de solidarité en
plus donc de la convention santé qui a
été évoquée et qui elle est en place
nous souhaitons rappeler à la commission
des finances donc des échanges sont en
cours en fait entre le pays et le
gouvernement de la Polynésie française
le président Frisch l'a d'ailleurs
souligné la semaine dernière lors de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
de Polynésie française on indiquant que
ces discussions ne sont pas encore
achevées et qu'il fallait encore
travailler sur cette feuille de route
qui doit être définie avec des
engagements des deux côtés c'est
pourquoi la commission des finances
demande le retrait de cet amendement en
ayant bien entendu l'appel qui est
formulé et auquel la titre personnel je
me joins bien entendu
c'est donc une demande de retrait
de Monsieur le Ministre
comment ne pas être sensible aux
arguments du sénateur aux frites
je confirme l'ensemble de ce que dit le
président de la commission des finances
le rapporteur de la commission des
finances on est bien saisi on est bien
en cours c'est un vrai sujet nous
souhaitons de différer pour aboutir à
une vraie feuille de route si ça
aboutisse je l'espère j'ai l'engagement
de Madame la première minute de dégager
les crédits en 2023 donc ça c'est clair
et donc je m'associe la demande de la
commission des finances surtout lorsque
cette demande était mise par un sachant
absolu de ce qui est la santé en
Polynésie je souhaite donc le retrait de
cet amendement et à défaut un avis
défavorable
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
j'entends le rapporteur j'entends
monsieur le ministre mais vous avez à
juste titre spécifié que c'était indiqué
dans l'objet amendement d'appel mais je
vais le maintenir parce que je pense que
il est juste en fait cet amendement et
que tout à l'heure j'ai bien écouté
monsieur le ministre qui parlait qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire de lever des
gages qu'il y avait des lignes à
disposition donc je pense qu'il faut
maintenir cet amendement pour ces
raisons je vais le maintenir et aussi
parce que ce amendement déposé par notre
collègue du groupe Union centriste la
date et Tony nous surveille depuis la
Polynésie et j'espère que comme et nous
avons demandé d'ailleurs un scrutin
public qu'il sera voté largement par
notre assemblée je vous remercie tout à
fait et d'ailleurs comme je vois pas
d'explication de vote nous allons passer
au scrutin public sur cet amendement
le scrutin est ouvert
deux avis sont défavorables
personne ne demande à votre tél
vote en 343 exprimer 150 pour 150 contre
0 le Sénat a adopté ensuite quatre
amendements identiques en discussion
commune nous commençons avec
l'amendement la commission des finances
monsieur patient
[Musique]
un amendement augmentant de 30 millions
d'euros les crédits pour les corons a
été retenu dans le texte sur lequel le
gouvernement engagé sa responsabilité
en application de l'article 49 alinéa 3
de la Constitution
cependant sur ces 30 millions d'euros 20
millions sont destinés au syndicats
gestionnaires de l'eau et de
l'assainissement en Guadeloupe et 10
millions sont destinés à intégrer de
nouvelles communes dans cette
expérimentation
pour rappel lors de sa création loi de
finance initiale pour 2021 le dispositif
quorum avait été doté de 30 millions
d'euros en a eux et CP pour accompagner
les communes ultramarines faisant face à
des difficultés financières
ce montant a permis d'améliorer la
situation de 9 communes contractantes
Sada à Mayotte Saint-Benoît la Réunion
Cayenne miracubo en Guyane
Pointe-à-Pitre Saint-François et
Basse-Terre en Guadeloupe et
Fort-de-France et Saint-Pierre à la
Martinique qui se sont par ailleurs dans
le cadre de ces contrats engagés à
optimiser leur gestion et à fiabiliser
leurs comptes
cependant il apparaît indispensable de
poursuivre ce dispositif et d'ouvrir à
nouveau 30 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les communes les plus en
difficulté
or au terme du texte transmis par
l'Assemblée nationale seul 10 millions
d'euros en vocation à permettre
l'extension du dispositif à de nouvelles
communes 20 millions étant fléchés sur
les syndicats d'eau de la Guadeloupe
pourtant sur l'ensemble des dromes
l'encours de dette a augmenté de 36,6%
entre 2016 et 2021
passant de
2376,2 à
3246,5 millions d'euros sur la période
2016-2022 les ressources
d'investissement ont baissé de 31-47%
pour des charges d'investissement restés
stables
cette situation a pour conséquence
l'allongement des délais de paiement il
ressort des derniers rapports de lieu
d'homme sur les délais de paiement dans
les Drôme que le délai du secteur public
local et hospitalier c'est globalement
détérioré sur les 10 dernières années
passant d'un peu moins de 40 jours en
2012 après de 65 jours en 2021 soit un
niveau largement supérieur au plafond
réglementaire qui est de 30 jours pour
les collectivités locales
oui
un tout petit peu accéléré la
présentation de l'amendement vous avez
déjà mangé 30 secondes de plus de votre
temps de parole donc simplement j'ai
demandé à score Ken rallonge de 20
millions supplémentaires sur les
courants
[Musique]
identiques vos collègues continueront la
suite de l'exposé monsieur Mamet swahili
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
l'amendement vient d'être excellent
défendu par l'auteur de ce dispositif
Georges patient le dispositif Corum qui
a montré son efficacité c'est un
dispositif que je qualifierais de génial
qui est vertueux et efficace et ses
amendements
identiques tendent tout simplement à
augmenter les crédits de ce dispositif
afin que les collectivités d'outre-mer
qui veulent s'engager dans cette voie de
la vertu et de l'efficacité et bien
puisse le faire en grand nombre donc
nous soutenons cet amendement la
commission des lois la trouver tellement
géniale qu'il présente le même
amendement
vous considérez qu'il est défendu
oui c'est défendu mais je voudrais tout
simplement rappeler que le 23 novembre
dernier et bien le groupe socialiste par
ma voix a présenté hockey sur le
gouvernement
sa dispositif parce que beaucoup d'élus
et particulièrement des maires des
Outre-mer son volontaires pour que ce
budget soit alloué afin qu'il puisse
également en bénéficier merci merci
Monsieur Théophile est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait rapidement juste pour
louer les bienfaits de ce dispositif
puisque attention ça à la fois il vient
voler financier bien sûr mais elle
voulait d'ingénierie ce qui fait que et
on le sait très bien quand les communes
les collectivités dans les territoires
d'outre-mer vont mieux et bien c'est la
commande publique qui augmente et c'est
le développement économique tout
s'enchaînent et donc par conséquent
c'est un dispositif très profitable à
ses 26 communes à peu près en Guadeloupe
qui sont dans des situations difficiles
mais qui devrait s'en sortir petit à
petit si ces sont appliqués quelle est
la vie du gouvernement sur ses
amendements
sur ses amendements je voudrais tout
d'abord me féliciter de l'existence de
ce processus auquel le sénateur patient
n'est pas
étranger nous avions 10 millions d'euros
par an
ça permettait de couvrir cette commune
de contracter avec cette commune on a
décidé d'en avoir deux parce que avec 10
millions par an on peut on peut faire 9
communes
dans ce qui a été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale il y a 30 millions vous l'avez
rappelé dans 20 millions pour le SMIC et
10 millions pour l'extension du corps
c'est-à-dire que d'une année sur l'autre
nous doublons nous doublons la capacité
moi je trouve que c'est bien nous
doublons la capacité c'est même
extraordinaire un processus qui marche
on double du jour au lendemain à côté de
ce système Corum pour aider les
entreprises pour aider que ça marche je
rappelle ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
à la tribune sur la création de
points d'expertise France délocalisé
automatique pour aider à consommer les
crédits et ça va aider les choses et
d'autre part je travaille je l'ai dit
aussi avec
la Banque Postale et
la Banque Postale et l'AFD à la mise en
place d'un espèce de facturage inversé
qui permettra de réduire les difficultés
pour les entreprises qui subissent des
délais de paiement trop long
pour toutes ces raisons je pense que
doubler les crédits d'un système qui
fonctionne c'est bien si je pouvais
faire ça sur toutes les lignes
budgétaires ça serait parfait donc je
pense que nous devons nous réjouir de
ces 10 millions consacrés ça double et
pour cela que j'ai un avis défavorable
sur le sujet
très bien
madame ranconne
on était invention c'est pour soutenir
ce dispositif et soutenir les
amendements qui ont été déposés par nos
collègues le collègues de Mayotte a eu
l'occasion de le dire Tani Mohamed soit
lit et c'est un dispositif génial c'est
vrai et on voit aujourd'hui les
résultats donc il faut continuer
d'accompagner les communes augmenter la
cible et permettre à tous ces mers qui
sont demandeurs d'en bénéficier c'est
peut-être une somme investir tout de
suite mais il y a tellement de
répétitions positives derrière
l'État va retrouver en taxe en
mobilisation en emploi le centuple donc
soutient total pour ses amendements
madame jasmin monsieur le ministre le 23
novembre dernier le ministre Auban a
répondu favorablement en faveur
justement
lorsque j'ai posé la question
gouvernement et bien elle est dans le
bon sens il y a la promis alors il
faudrait vous mettre d'accord et mettre
travail et ensemble
merci je vais donc mettre voir ses
amendements identiques monsieur
doublé passé de 9 à 18 c'est un peu
quand même faible quand on sait que 64
communes d'outre-mer sur 124 sont dans
le réseau d'alerte
très bien je vais donc mettre voir ses
amendements identiques qui ont reçu un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
le président
ils sont adoptés le 927 madame assassin
mais monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues notre
amendement porte sur la problématique de
l'amiante dans les outre-mer parce
qu'une étude réalisée par le mystère des
Outre-mer en 2020 a montré qu'il y avait
un problème avec la mise en place d'une
filière de traitement sur place des des
déchets
anéantés bien évidemment ils peuvent pas
être transférés ailleurs il y a une
problématique qui est spécifique et qui
fait que ce traitement serait sans doute
pas rentable uniquement avec les moyens
de l'outre-mer c'est pour ça que nous
proposons cette cette aide afin de
permettre un deuxième montage important
des installations il y a autant
d'amiantes en métropole que sur les
outre-mer mais comme vous l'avez compris
dans les outre-mer il y a une
problématique spécifique merci madame la
Présidente de la Commission
oui merci madame la Présidente dans cet
amendement prévoit une augmentation de
15 millions d'euros des crédits à louer
à la LBU pour les opérations des amis en
page le traitement de l'amiante est
extrêmement onéreux nous le savons et en
l'absence de gestion locale de ces
matériaux le déchets d'Amiens sont
envoyés par containers vers l'Hexagone
pour être traités
de nombreuses difficultés dans la
conduite des chantiers de réhabilitation
menées dans tous les territoires une
étude a été lancée par la dgom en 2020
sur les perspectives d'installation
d'une filière amiante en outre-mer
cependant les débouchés ne sont pas
opérationnels je cite il est donc
effectivement nécessaire outre
l'organisation de filière locale de
désamiantage de développer une aide
destinée au traitement de l'amiante
spécifique au Drôme au Drôme cependant
il nous semble que c'est crédits
devraient plutôt être portés par Lana ou
la rue pour des montants sans doute
beaucoup plus importants que se proposer
par le présentement pour mémoire la
présence d'amiante a conduit à enchir
les coûts démolition des tours gabards à
Pointe-à-Pitre de 12,7 millions d'euros
à 30,37 millions d'euros
c'est pour que c'est pourquoi nous
sommes convaincus à la commission des
finances la nécessité de l'ouverture de
crédit pour ces travaux de désamantage
mais pas nécessairement uniquement sur
le crédit de la mission outre-mer aussi
nous demandant l'avis du Gouvernement
sur ce point
vous vous en doutez les relations sont
fortes et tendues avec la rue et Lana je
vais signaler que dans les cinq drones
le nombre de réhabilitations par exemple
est passé de 1700 unités en 2021 à plus
de 6000 en 2022 je vais rappeler ce
qu'on essaye de faire sur je l'ai dit
Fort de France et Pointe-à-Pitre avec
des opérations spécialisées il y a
beaucoup de communes qui sont très
touchées par ça il y a un peu la Réunion
aussi je pense que la
disponibilité des crédits au sein de la
LBU crédit qui sont
aménageables en permanence la première
ministre l'a rappelé les relations que
j'ai avec la rue et Lana font que je
suis désolé de vous dire que si j'avais
ces crédits je pense que je ne les
emploie pas donc autant ne pas les
prendre et espérer les avoir ailleurs
plus tard donc c'est un avis défavorable
je vous remercie je vais donc mettre au
bois cet amendement qui a reçu alors un
avis défavorable du gouvernement et par
conséquent ça fait quel avis de la
commission
donc
monsieur le ministre on renvoie dans un
problème entre l'anal en U et le môme
c'est dommage hein mais en attendant il
y a une population qui est extrêmement
souffrances à cause de l'amiante
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas réhabiliter à
minima les chambres du CHU pierre-hop
dakitman notre CHU plus de 700 chambres
dans un état de délabrement total
dès laboiement total à cause de
l'amiante il y a de la myope partout
dans la peinture dans l'École etc par
ailleurs dans l'habitat privé dans
l'habitat normal
je prends l'exemple et j'ai une forte
pensée pour eux des habitants de cité
grenade à joues pas bouillon qui vont
être bientôt
expulsés de leur logement logé ailleurs
pour permettre de mettre à niveau ses
logements qui sont bourrés d'amiante
aujourd'hui la filière est en grande
difficulté les délais d'attente sont
énormes et je ne vous y pas la surencher
qui existe avec parfois une seule
entreprise
qui impose des délais énormes de
traitement avec des tarifs de monopoles
sur ce problème d'amiante donc je sais
pas qui doit la gérer la NA opèrent très
peu chez nous par exemple la rue ce sont
des programmes qui sont plus vie
annuelles qui sont lourds et tout
qu'est-ce qui nous reste notre ministère
monsieur le ministre
Cancun vous le savez bien mais c'est des
effets de manche que vous faites que le
problème du CHU n'a rien à voir avec ce
sujet là il y a effectivement de la
merde non c'est pas le budget de
l'outre-mer qui va réhabiliter tout le
programme du CHU on a des problèmes de
santé un peu partout mais globalement je
dirais que le ministère de la Santé sur
les constructions est très attentifs à
ce qui se passe et très peut-être
nouvel hôpital à Mayotte c'est quand
même aussi quelque chose si si la
réhabilitation et la construction et la
construction d'outils de santé et
d'hôpitaux il y a celui de chez vous
aussi à Saint-Pierre Miquelon sur lequel
il faut travailler encore donc c'est le
ministère de la santé il le fait bien on
va pas désamiant refaire le centre
hospitalier de Pointe-à-Pitre avec les
crédits de l'ABU quand même quand même
c'est pas c'est 15 millions c'est
quand c'est passé pour refaire l'hôpital
de Pointe-à-Pitre
pas du tout
l'hôpital de Pointe-à-Pitre est à
refaire aussi non
peu importe toute façon on a des crédits
on a des crédits à la santé pour refaire
l'ensemble des choses la Guadeloupe
c'est parti
c'est parti quand même bien et même bien
parti donc je ne je rappelle enfin qu'on
est passé de 1700 à 6000 logements
réhabiliter donc c'est faux de dire
qu'il se passe rien je suis désolé il se
passe pas assez vite oui vous avez dit
que les réhabilitations ne se faisaient
pas on est passé de 1700 assimiles c'est
bien il faut aller au-delà pour ça il
nous faut aller chercher les crédits de
la rue de Lana et c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire
je suis désolé elle est déjà faite votre
explication de votre
ah bah c'est ce qu'on appelle une
explication de vote je suis désolé
oui c'est une explication de vote
ah c'est une nouvelle catégorie qui est
pas encore identifiée par le règlement
celle-ci non non il n'y a qu'une il n'y
a qu'une intervention sur un des
amendements c'est l'explication de vote
là nous avons un amendement vous avez
bien de faire une explication de vote
non on est prise de parole peut être sur
l'article et puis après sur les
amendements c'est l'explication de vote
et à la fin sur l'article il peut voir
aussi une explication de votre sur
l'article
je n'en doute pas
j'en doute pas je vais donc mettre voir
l'amendement 927 et un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté madame cocotte vous donne la
parole pour défendre votre amendement 88
je crois que parfois monsieur le
ministre a dit problème de perception de
ce qu'on dit
deuxièmement je vais pas payer en mettre
à Monsieur le Ministre de dire que je
fais des efforts de manches
restons dans un registre respectueux les
uns les autres je suis ici pour défendre
ma population et quand je vois qu'il y a
une possibilité une fois d'être de tir
pour pouvoir en tirer de l'équité et de
la justice pour elle je montrais aucune
je ne veux pas qu'on parle de mes
interventions en terme d'effet de moche
je ne fais pas l'effet de moche
je crois être rigoureuse et sérieuse
dans la dans l'accomplissement de mon
travail de parlementaire depuis le
premier jour que j'ai été élu alors pas
de caricature
j'aurais pu en faire pour le ministre
également je ne fais pas par respect
pour lui
remettons les choses le Bono
on a maintenant le 88
là non plus ce n'est pas un effet de
manche c'est une réalité entre les
années 60 et 82 la France a installé un
dépend massif vers la métropole
des pas massif au travers de bureau qui
s'appelait le bureau d'immigration des
dômes le bumido
des dizaines de milliers de Guadeloupe
et de martiniquais de Réunionnais sont
partis ils ont donc vidé ces pays de
leur jeunesse de l'époque
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons dans ce
des peuplement massif je répète massif
avec une perte de population de 4500
habitants par an pour la seule
Martinique je vous laisse imaginer à ce
rythme qui a commencé depuis 10 ans donc
il semble inéluctable combien nous
serons dans 20 dans 30 ans
très proche de l'inexistant
donc je demande là de la même manière
que des moyens importants avaient été
mis pour créer le bumidum qu'il y ait
également la création d'une véritable
détermination pour accompagner ces
populations qui sont favorables au
retour donc un but dans mon retour en
quelque sorte entre guillemets doté de 5
millions d'euros
merci Madame ranconne quelle est la
ville de la Commission sur cette
amendement
font pour la mobilité auto pour lutter
contre la fuite des cerveaux et le
déclin démographique doté de 5 millions
d'euros il est certain que la mise en
place d'une stratégie générale
pourraient favoriser le retour des
jeunes ultramarins parti notamment pour
étudier en métropole ou à l'étranger
ministre même
d'abord
si nécessairement d'excuse je dis pas du
tout vous baisser dans mon esprit ce que
je dis n'était pas du tout une critique
je vous prie de m'excuser justement
qu'on retire mes paroles si ça vous a
blessé
aucun doute sur votre détermination
positive à défendre les outre-mer et
vous le savez sur cette ce sujet-là moi
je me râlerai à ce que j'ai
interprétiens c'est le bimmy dôme il
faut bien se mettre en tête que dans
notre esprit collectif le babydome c'est
fini
il y a des fois des choses que je vois
passer de la part de certains qui nous
plaisent pas
ce que vous demandez d'ailleurs vous
demander à ce que ce programme soit géré
par la Dom
je pense que c'est le boulot de la Dom
de le faire mais vraiment c'est le
boulot de la dame et je suis prêt au
sein des missions que je veux confier à
la Dom d'écrire spécifiquement cela
spécifiquement cela et je pense
d'ailleurs que le directeur de la dame
pourrait utilement dès qu'il sera nommé
être convoqué je peux me permettre sans
porter un tas tel indépendance du Sénat
convoqué par tel ou telle commission en
tout cas je souhaiterais que la
délégation
parlementaire le convoque pour bien
qu'on se mette en ligne sur la politique
que doit mener la Dom donc au nom des 47
millions
dont dispose la dôme aujourd'hui avec la
volonté d'avoir une politique concertée
de la Dom demain matin et la capacité de
trouver les crédits
le moment venu je sollicite le retrait
de cet amendement et sinon un avis
défavorable
ment qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté madame Kong 810
juste pour revenir rapidement sur le
vote Président je ne partage pas du tout
les propos de mon collègue Georges
patient sur l'attractivité on en parlera
après
alors concernant la LBU oui la LBU est
toujours bien dispositif pour construire
c'est un dispositif d'aide à la pierre
il y a pas de problème c'est un
dispositif qui fonctionne bien qui vient
aider à la fois la réhabilitation à la
construction de nouveaux logements pas
de problème les bailleurs ça fait les
opérateurs sociaux ça fait donc c'est
une ligne qui fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui les bailleurs sont
confrontés à un immense problème celui
que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure dans ma
discussion générale
le vivre ensemble est extrêmement
difficile les bailleurs se trouvent
confrontés à inventer de nouveaux
métiers de nouveaux métiers ils sont à
la fois psychologue travaillant sociaux
assistants sociaux et figurez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui une association pour le
logement social a dû être monté par
cofinancement des trois bailleurs
majeurs de Martinique pour leur
permettre de prendre en charge ces
populations
40% du parc est aujourd'hui atteint de
maladies mentales
40% du parc le vieillissement c'est plus
de 70% du parc de personnes de plus de
65 ans donc beaucoup présente des
troubles liés au vieillissement les
bailleurs sont obligés d'inventer de
nouveaux métiers il en faut des moyens
la LS cette fameuse association de je
vous parle est doté du mieux qu'elle
peut par les bailleurs eux-mêmes sur des
fonds qui sont du inventer c'est pas
leur métier ils n'ont pas les budgets
pour ça ils l'ont quand même fait n'a
que 6 salariés 6 salariés pour prendre
des milliers des milliers et des
milliers de cas en charge donc
aujourd'hui il faut aller un peu plus
dans la dentelle en matière de politique
publique et à cette dans cet esprit je
demande qu'une partie de la LBU très
symboliquement soit fléchés sur
l'accompagnement social des bailleurs
sociaux et leur permettre en tout cas de
mieux rendre leur politique publique du
mieux vivre ensemble merci quelle est la
ville de la Commission
c'est amusement vise à majorer de 5
millions d'euros
des crédits de la LBU afin de créer un
volet social qui permettrait
d'accompagner les bailleurs sociaux
je comprends parfaitement les
préoccupations des signataires de cet
amendement et il faut effectivement
saluer le travail des bailleurs qui ont
tenté sur leur fonds propres de mettre
en place des solutions mais ces
dernières ne peuvent être que
provisoires et incomplètes le problème
de trop psychologique de marginalisation
de violences ou d'alcoolisme dans les
territoires d'outre-mer ne sont pas du
ressort des bailleurs sociaux qui
interviennent dans l'urgence avec des
mesures palliatifs mais qui ne règnent
rien le problème ce débat doit mon sens
est porté sur des crédits du budget du
ministère des solidarités de la santé
que des crédits supplémentaires soient
nécessaires est indéniable qui soit
ouvert sur la LBU de la mission
outre-mer me paraît en revanche beaucoup
plus contestable
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
la nécessité absolue de faire quelque
chose moi je m'engage publiquement à ce
que les associations de bailleurs sur
mes crédits associatifs sur mes crédits
associatifs nous saisissez de faire cet
effort de lancement de quelque chose de
prise en compte à une hauteur
significative cette association bailleur
si nécessaire ou autre sur la prise en
charge de ce problème qui est
fondamental j'abandonnerai ce fond je te
signale des crédits pour cette
association
je me vois c'est un moment double vie
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
j'ai extrêmement compliqué aussi
nous avons pu obtenir votre favorable
pour réduire la tigerap de 50% ou 200 %
sur une période transitoire pour
permettre la mise à niveau des
investissements
concernant la gestion des déchets vous
savez quand on vit sur une île c'est la
plupart des cas des îles en dehors du
territoire de mon collègue patient qui
est un vrai continent
évacuer les déchets c'est compliqué ce
qui était les déchets c'est compliqué
valoriser les déchets c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui les syndicats mixtes
souffrent énormément et présente des
déficits importants concernant tous ces
investissements qui sont à réaliser dans
la plus grande urgence pour pouvoir être
aux normes totalement aux normes pour
répondre aux questions
normales de développement durable le
plus simple possible le plus vertueux
possible en matière de gestion de
déchets donc je demande qu'une
particulier pour la collecter le
traitement des déchets en outre-mer que
ça relève d'un fond exceptionnel le
temps pour ces structures de se mettre à
niveau en matière d'investissement une
simple ligne de fou qui est nécessaire à
l'usine de sidération de Ford de France
c'est 50 millions d'euros
quelle est la ville de la Commission
pour la collecte et le traitement des
déchets à notre mère doté de 5 millions
d'euros
dans un contexte de recherche permanente
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone de nos
activités et de réchauffement climatique
le traitement des déchets doit se faire
au plus près de leur lieu de collecte il
y a par ailleurs un enjeu sanitaire
important pour les populations cependant
la pression foncière ne facilite pas la
réalisation des installations de
traitement et des financements
importants existent déjà via la DM le
FUI ou les fonds européen je
solliciterai pour cet amendement
néanmoins la vie du gouvernement
sujet important notamment en Martinique
mais aussi à Saint-Martin que je connais
et à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon un peu partout
j'apprécie ce que ce fond il existe il a
été dépensé à hauteur de ce que vous
demandez en 2000
en 2021 puisque sur le FEI 6,3 millions
d'euros ont été mobilisés sur trois
projets en Guyane en 2021 c'est déjà
plus que les 5 millions en
2022,8 millions étaient mobilisés dont 2
millions à Mayotte et 0,8 pour un projet
en Martinique il nous faut aller au-delà
comme sur beaucoup de sujets je pense
qu'il nous faut d'abord travailler avant
de donner des crédits on a un atelier je
dirais ordures ménagères et déchets à la
Martinique ou le syndicat mix ne va pas
bien vous le savez
ils veulent piquer les sous du sénateurs
patients pour un quorum d'ailleurs
on verra donc je pense que vous avez
raison sur le fond mais que
budgétairement
je peux pas le faire parce qu'on
m'objectera évidemment ministère des
Finances qui a déjà un fond qui
fonctionne pour cela
propose un avis défavorable
par conséquent la commission
défavorable je mets au voie cet
amendement double avis défavorable qui
est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le
18e rapporteurs
je prends plus de risques maintenant
merci madame la Présidente donc c'est un
amendement qui vise à augmenter de 5
millions d'euros les crédits à louer au
financement de l'économie outre-mer donc
action 4 du programme 138 cette action
créée en loi de finance pour 2019 pour
des mesures spécifiques de soutien aux
entreprises et associations de
tramarines et après objectif
d'accompagner le développement
économique l'attractivité nos
territoires ultramarins par la mise en
œuvre de plusieurs dispositifs vous les
connaissez le prêt de développement
outre-mer des pays France les
subventions d'investissement le soutient
microcrédit outre-mer l'aide au fret
2023 les crédits de l'action 4 s'élève à
24,3 millions d'euros en AE et 21,8
millions d'euros en CP soit un niveau
strictement équivalent celui la loi de
finance initiale 2022 on a eu en légère
baisse en CP ce niveau de crédit
identique à celui des années précédentes
interroge cependant en effet en 2020 et
importante surexécution des crédits de
cette action était constaté notamment en
raison du contexte de crise sanitaire
qui est engendrait un accroissement des
demandes de financement via le
dispositif pédom pour les entreprises
ultramarines qui ont rencontré des
difficultés financières globalement il
nous a pas évident que la consommation
de ces crédits est très sensible à la
conjoncture économique dans le contexte
économique actuel la situation des
entreprises en 2023 devraient se
détériorer ou en tout cas faire appel à
ce type d'intervention le recours
microcrédit ou au pdom pourrait avoir
alors enregistrer une hausse importante
par rapport à 2021 voir 2022 il nous
apparaît donc nécessaire d'augmenter les
crédits de cette action afin de
préserver le tissu économique local
notamment les petites entreprises qui
seront durement affectées par la hausse
de l'inflation en 2023 afin de respecter
les règles de recevabilité budgétaire
cet amendement prélève 5 millions
d'euros en a eu en CP sur programme 123
conditions de vie outre-mer action 8
pour aborder le programme 138 action 4
merci
merci quelle est la vie du gouvernement
sur cet amendement de la commission
la vie du gouvernement c'est d'abord que
le ministère d'outre-mer communique mal
à la suite de cet amendement
en octobre 2022 il y a peu c'est sur les
crédits de mon ministère et sur ma
décision attribué 2 millions d'euros à
BPI France pour couvrir le prochain
exercice
par ailleurs un nouveau produit près de
développement outre-mer transmission va
être mis en place afin d'accompagner
financièrement les transmissions
d'entreprise
7,5 millions d'euros lui ont été loués à
BPI garantis pour assurer cette mission
c'est donc au delà déjà de la demande
s'agissant de l'aide au fret
je veux dire que là aussi on a un
problème structurel bizarrement les
crédits de l'aide aux frais tels qu'ils
sont organisés je découvre
l'organisation avec des procédures
impensables avec les régions les avis
d'un tel et d'un tel ces crédits ne sont
pas utilisés des crédits ne sont pas
utilisés c'est l'argent que l'état donne
aux régions pour le faire et ça se fait
pas alors il faut plonger dedans et
c'est de regarder mais j'ai pas su le
communiquer c'est la première fois que
je le dis comme cela par ailleurs une
politique volontariste d'appui au
secteur du microcrédit de l'économie
sociale
a été mise en place qu'un mobiliser 2
millions on a eu en CP en 2022 on a
essayé d'élargir notre action en faveur
des PME de l'économie sociale et
solidaire à France Active à initiation à
initiative outre-mer
et je pense que en gestion sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire
simplement on arrivera à bander monsieur
le sénateur je suis désolé de dire que
c'est fait mais j'ai pas su communiquer
donc avis défavorable pour doubler la
mise ok je vais donc mettre au voie sa
maman qui a reçu un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
un moment de la commission qui a reçu un
avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui est contre
voilà l'idée
5 amendement identique
messieurs les rapporteurs
d'euros les crédits à louer à la
réception de l'habitat indigne et
insalubre en outre-mer les crédits à
louer à cette action sont stables depuis
plusieurs années à un niveau de 20
millions d'euros en CP et 15 millions
d'euros en a eu or les drones présentent
une proportion de logements indignés
salubre nettement supérieur à la
métropole en effet près de 19 4% du parc
de logement soit environ 150 000
habitants sur les
10774641 résidence principale que quand
le parc est concerné contre 1,2% en
France métropolitaine
en octobre 2022 les 15 millions d'euros
ouverts en LFI à ce titre était
intégralement consommé afin de respecter
les règles de recevabilité budgétaire
ces amendement après les 4 millions
d'euros on a eu et en CP sur l'action de
aide à l'insertion et la qualification
professionnelle du programme 138 emplois
outre-mer pour abonder le programme 123
action 1
Jacques il est vendu merci Monsieur
Mohamed Soignies défendu
[Musique]
similaire qui vise à renforcer les
crédits dédiés à la résolution de
l'habitat insalubre outre-mer
Théophile défendu également quelle est
la vie du gouvernement sur ses
amendements identiques
favorable sans lever de gage on le
prendra sur l'ensemble du programme pas
sur le bu on le prendra sur l'ensemble
du programme
c'est un sujet absolument pas moi je
voulais dire aussi pour un fou de pour
information du Sénat et des
parlementaires que sur le crédit
logement il y a la LBU il y a les 400
millions d'euros
2000 résidus reliquat du FIV du pif
pardon du pif que j'essaye de reporter
et puis la bagarre qu'on mène pour avoir
du snapp qui viendra à aborder l'habitat
indigne donc
ça va dans ce sens donc je suis
favorable et quand je vois les problèmes
je m'excuse de le dire que j'ai enfin de
gestion pour dépenser tous mes crédits
je ne lève pas le gaz
bien je mets au voisin
identique conventionnel du gouvernement
qui est pour qui compte qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés le 929 monsieur Julias
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur Miss
mes chers collègues
84% de la population de Mayotte vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté c'est un chiffre
terrible
qui fait frémir et monsieur le ministre
c'est une plaie béante au cœur de la
République la République c'est la
fraternité on peut pas accepter qu'il
est 84% d'une population qui vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté alors ce qu'on vous
propose bien évidemment c'est
extrêmement modeste mais c'est au moins
pour pour corriger cette injustice qui
est absolument monstrueuse c'est des
crédits qui permettent de place de
mettre en place un chèque alimentaire
pour soulager un petit peu cette musée
cette misère qui est complètement
inconcevable au cœur de la République
merci madame la Présidente
quelle est la ville de la Commission sur
cet amendement oui madame la Présidente
donc c'est un moment prévoit une
augmentation de 4 millions d'euros ça a
été rappelé pour chaque alimentaire
Mayotte en 2021,6 millions d'euros avait
été déployés pour trois mois sous la
forme de chaque d'urgence alimentaire
pour environ 13300 familles de Mayotte
c'était d'absolument nécessaire dans
cependant pas résolu le problème de fond
et le besoin persiste en raison du
niveau de grande pauvreté des habitants
de Mayotte vous l'avez souligné par
rapport à la métropole mais également
par rapport aux autres territoires
d'outre-mer cependant le PLF 2023 ne
comporte pas de chèque alimentaire jugé
complexe à mettre en place pareil aussi
cette problématique est plaignante à
Mayotte tel touche également de nombreux
citoyens français quel que soit leur
lieu de résidence la réponse doit être
globale au même titre que ce qui a pu
être fait sur les aides au ménage face à
la hausse des prix de l'énergie aussi
nous souhaitons la vie du gouvernement
pour savoir notamment où on sent les
réflexions sur le fond pour une aide
alimentaire durable de 60 millions 2023
annoncé par la première ministre ou tout
autre dispositif d'aide alimentaire donc
c'est un avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le ministre
je rappelle que dans le cadre du PSR
l'aide avec le soutien résolu du
gouvernement c'est 4,8 millions d'euros
qui ont été attribués malheureusement on
préfère et qu'on ait besoin de rien
4,8 millions d'euros
qui a été enfin quatre fois attribué à
Mayotte soit quatre fois plus que le
montant initial prévu pour 2022
et ça c'est peut-être par et peut-être
pas vrai
je préfère qu'on fasse financer ça par
le FSE qui a prévu 5 millions d'euros
de bons alimentaires à partir de 2024
sur la période de trois ans donc ça fait
à peu près un million 8 d'euros
supplémentaire qu'on va les chercher sur
le FSE
ça me paraît de bonne politique et le
FSE à l'état on va peut-être arriver à
décider si la programmation des fonds
européens par l'État s'améliore mais
j'étais à Bruxelles là-dessus et André
pouvoir le faire plus le dispositif PMR
plus les budgets quand même des
collectivités locales donc c'est aussi
notamment le conseil territorial ce me
semble déjà important si nécessaire on y
reviendra en PLF mais j'aimerais bien
d'abord vérifier que tout ce qui est
prévu arrive et donc c'est à la fois
regret mais aussi par sincérité que je
donne un avis défavorable quelle est la
ville de la commission après la vie du
gouvernement
identique d'accord je mets aux voix cet
amendement 929 double avis défavorable
qui est pour
qui contre
il est
je recommence qui est pour
il est adopté le 393 monsieur Artano
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon c'est un oui
madame Dinard
pour le 392
92 et pas le 392 et c'est Madame merci
madame la Présidente cet amendement vise
à augmenter de 2 millions d'euros les
crédits à louer aux associations qui
luttent contre les violences
intrafamilales dans les outre-mer en
effet on connaît le gâche humain que
constitue ces violences sur
l'épanouissement et la protection pas
seulement des femmes mais surtout des
enfants en lien avec les niveaux de vie
les différences culturelles la
confrontation modernité et société
traditionnelles et donc on demande de
retirer 2 millions d'euros sur l'action
1 afin de les redéployer à l'action 4
sanitaires sociales culture du programme
123 c'est un vrai sujet monsieur le
ministre bien sûr il y a le droit commun
mais je crois que le ministère qui gère
nos territoires doit donner un signal à
l'ensemble des associations qui
travaillent contre ces violences
intrafamilales qui constituent un gros
gâchis pour le futur de nos populations
quelle est la ville de la Commission
sensible et qui doit tous nous mobiliser
en outre-mer selon l'Insee les violences
intrafamiliales mesurent et à partir des
dépôts de plein sont encore plus
répandus que dans l'Hexagone en 2020
7652 femmes ont encore été victime de
violences sur l'ensemble des dromes
contre 7263 en 2019 soit un taux de
victimisation de 5,4 contre 3,1
7 fois plus élevée
il faut lutter contre ce phénomène c'est
une évidence
pour autant je ne pense pas que les
crédits de la mission outre-mer soit le
meilleur vecteur pour renforcer cette
lutte actuellement les crédits à louer
aux actions du lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales sont portées
par le ministère en charge des droits
des femmes et nous ne revient pas dans
le cadre de l'examen de la mission
outre-mer de préconiser leur
augmentation cependant il est indéniable
qu'il faut améliorer l'information sur
les crédits spécifiquement à l'eau à
l'Outre-mer et intégrer au document de
politique transversal outre-mer
une annexe sur ce sujet permettrait de
connaître précisément les moyens alloués
en outre-mer pour lutter contre ces
violences et je profite de l'occasion
pour demander le gouvernement sur une
telle évolution serait possible à court
terme lplf 2024
pour moi j'ai mis un avis défavorable
ministre quelle
est la vie 2 minutes sur le sujet de
l'amendement précédent avec monsieur le
sénateur nous sommes parlés dire à tout
le monde que le taux de pauvreté baisse
à Mayotte il baisse même relativement
fortement et oui alors au nom de ça ça
conforte l'idée que j'ai qu'on progresse
et qui nous faut encore progresser sur
la cet amendement
qui vient d'être évoqué
c'est effectivement le Ministère chargé
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la diversité de l'égalité des chances
qui est compétent et il est en hausse il
est en hausse sur le programme outre-mer
puisqu'il était de 2 millions d'euros en
2021 de 3 millions d'euros en 2022 et de
3 millions d'euros en 2023 donc on a
augmenté de 50 % en deux ans par
ailleurs par ailleurs compte tenu de
l'importance du sujet les contrats de
convergence et de transformation ont
prévu des crédits d'État contractualisés
par période 2019-2022 programmé jusqu'en
2023 mais on aura la moyenne 4 millions
d'euros sur le programme 137 400 000 sur
le programme 123 sur 4 ans ça fait à peu
près un million d'euros en plus en outre
des appels à projets sur les crédits
associatifs sur les crédits associatifs
sont lancés et ainsi 325000 euros sont
financés par le ministère des outre-mer
pour 38 projets ultramarins pour cette
même année 2021 c'est 500.000 euros
qui ont été versés des associations pour
les luttes contre les violences
conjugales nous aurons là aussi ce même
montant sur les crédits associatifs sur
les volumes sur les violences conjugales
avec en plus peut-être une demande
supplémentaire parce que la prise de
conscience devient plus forte la prise
de conscience devient plus forte c'est
donc pour
au nom de l'ensemble de ces crédits
supplémentaires qui sont de ces crédits
qui existent déjà près de 4 millions par
an que j'ai mis un avis défavorable
tant bien monsieur le rapporteur et
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre ce
que vous venez d'évoquer bien évidemment
si on parle d'une somme de 4 millions
d'euros on sait bien vous et moi sur ces
banques c'est largement insuffisant pour
lutter contre les violences
intrafamilales les violences
intrafamilales ça concerne tous les
domaines que ce soit à la santé pour
simplement l'écoute de ces femmes qui
ont du mal à trouver et aujourd'hui les
hôpitaux proposent même d'avoir des
assistances sociaux pour pouvoir les
aider les collectivités territoriales
que nous sommes nous mettons également
de l'argent la main à la pâte on ne peut
pas voter un bleu de l'outre-mer avec
les conditions de vie sans que malgré
tout on donne un signal pour montrer que
ces violences là qui touchent les
enfants qui touchent l'avenir de nos
populations qui touchent j'ai envie de
dire une approche humaine GL si on ne
donne pas ce signal pourquoi je vous
demande monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs les rapporteurs dit
tenir compte parce que les associations
qui luttent sur le terrain les
associations de proximité bien sûr ces
associations ont besoin d'aide bien sûr
que nous connaissons les appels à
projets bien sûr que nous savons qu'on
fait des efforts mais c'est tellement et
largement insuffisant que vraiment c'est
2 millions d'euros permettrait aux
associations de terrain de montrer que
un ministère qui gère tous ces
territoires et pris en compte ce dossier
ce défi à relever aujourd'hui et demain
pour l'ensemble des territoires
concernés par les violences
intrafamiliales
madame jasmin
monsieur la ministre même la présidente
monsieur le ministre c'est la grande
cause du quinquennat et c'était la
grande cause du quinquennat précédent
donc les associations jouent rôle
essentiel sur nos territoires et c'est
vrai que le nombre de féminicides bon en
outre-mer y compris dans l'ensemble de
la France je dirais ça augmente chaque
année les associations joueurs
importantes et de proximité mais toutes
les associations ne sont pas forcément
en mesure de répondre aux appels à
projets et il y a un tri sélectif qui se
fait alors que toutes les associations
ont une utilité sur chacun de nos
territoires donc c'est à prendre en
compte également merci monsieur
oui merci madame la Présidente comme
vient de le dire notre collègue Victor
jasmin c'était une grande cause du
quinquennat précédent et une grande
cause du président quinquennat et il
faut il faut reconnaître que des progrès
significatifs indéniables ont été
accomplis ces dernières années dans la
lutte contre ce fléau mais ce fléau
persiste demeure et tu et surtout dans
les territoires ultramarins comme je
l'avais rappelé lors de l'examen de la
loop me les violences intrafamiliales
sont plus répandues à notre mère que
dans l'Hexagone à Mayotte par exemple
chaque année environ 650 femmes
franchissent courageusement à la porte
du commissariat de Mamoudzou ou d'une
brigade de gendarmerie de Lille pour
signaler des violences conjugales seul
150 de ce signalement donne lieu à des
procédures judiciaires des moyens sont
mis en oeuvre pour aider les victimes et
sensibiliser les professionnels aux
différentes spécificités je pense
notamment à la publication en juillet
2022 d'un nouveau guide sur les
violences faites aux femmes dans les
outre-mer élaborés par la Mission
interministérielle pour la protection
des femmes contre les violences et la
lutte contre la traite des êtres humains
à destination des professionnels ou
encore à la mise en service du 39-19
joignable 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 à notre mère
néanmoins les efforts doivent se
poursuivre et les moyens renforcés afin
de lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales en outre-mer pour un
accueil une orientation et une
protection des victimes plus efficace
aussi je partage le constat de notre
collègue nous le vivons au quotidien
mais il ne s'agit pas que d'un problème
de crédit ou de personnel nous avons un
sujet de libération de la parole et de
prise en charge des victimes monsieur le
ministre je crois savoir qu'un texte est
en cours de préparation avec la ministre
Isabelle Rome sur ce sujet c'est une
demande formelle et appuyée que je vous
adresse associez les parlementaires
ultramarins à l'élaboration de ce texte
pour prendre en compte nos spécificités
dans ma vie j'ai tout à l'heure je
parlais de l'importance de l'intention
voilà une belle intention
à ses intentions qui sont vitales le
cadet de la condition des femmes et des
violences faites aux femmes dans nos
territoires reconnus totalement
supérieur à ce qui se passe ailleurs
l'observat les observatoires ont été mis
en place et peuvent en attester et bien
oui il y a une bonne raison d'y penser
une attention et une intention très
particulière donc je soutiens tout ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure et je
soutiens l'amendement de ma collègue
dinda
madame la Présidente merci merci madame
la Présidente moi je vais voter
l'amendement de ma collègue parce que
voilà je connais un peu Mayotte
et je connais bien sûr les violences en
général les violences bien sûr
intrafamiliales qui suivent c'est vrai
aussi dans l'Hexagone malheureusement et
je crois qu'il faut envoyer à la fois un
signal à la fois les crédits pour que
tout le monde puisse s'en occuper c'est
absolument aujourd'hui inadmissible
d'accepter ce qu'on voit alors peut-être
qu'on s'habitue monsieur le ministre je
crois qu'on doit jamais s'habituer et
les violences intrafamiliales
effectivement touche aussi les enfants
qui demain peut-être seront aussi ceux
qui vont amener les violences donc c'est
vraiment un sujet important et je moi je
vais voter cet amendement et j'invite
tous les collègues à le voter merci
de cet amendement je vais évidemment le
soutenir et puis j'en appelle à tous les
bons puisque il a été consigné par
l'ensemble des forces politiques
présentes dans l'hémicycle donc
j'appelle à ce que nous fassions front
sur ce sujet nous allons avec la
délégation en droit des femmes dans le
courant 2003 2023 travailler sur
l'accompagnement la parentalité on
outre-mer et je pense que ça fait
exactement écho à ce que vient de
soulever Nassima Dada et qui a été
repris sur tous les bancs et je pense
effectivement qu'on outremer plus
qu'ailleurs parce que le phénomène a été
observé il n'est pas imaginaire il y a
une démultiplication et un renforcement
des violences intra-familiales
auxquelles nous devons répondre et cet
amendement va dans le bon sens combien
même la politique gouvernementale
pourrait évoluer à terme sur ce sujet
je vais donc mettre en voix s'il n'y a
plus d'explication de vote double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre ça se tient il est adopté
monsieur Artano 393
monsieur qui
excusez-moi j'étais distraite distrait
c'est mon président qui me perturbe
complètement Saint-Pierre mi-temps c'est
250 km de côte linéaire fragilisés
régulièrement par les aléas climatiques
vous vous en doutez et c'est vrai que on
a unisme unique en France il faut bien
le dire de 12 km qui a été
particulièrement attaqué qui a subi des
affaissements la collectivité c'est
beaucoup mobilisé sur le sujet elle
s'est sentie beaucoup seule il faut bien
le dire on rencontre souvent sur les
collectivités à statut particulier
d'article 74 ayant une autonomie
administrative et fiscale pour répondre
tous les besoins mais dans ces cas-là on
a aussi besoin de soutien de l'État puis
d'une volonté de l'État de nous
accompagner le réchauffement climatique
et la montée des eaux viennent renforcer
ces phénomènes d'érosion qui se sont
accentués la collectivité c'est
véritablement engagée dans un processus
de course contre la vente elle est seule
l'état accompagne parfois en ingénierie
nous nous sommes heurtés fortement à la
technocratie de l'État à des études un
définir qui n'ont pas reçu certainement
de solutions qui avaient été préconisées
ont encore tout récemment sur le point
kilométrique numéro 16 les dégâts ont
été importants c'est un appel du pied
monsieur le ministre afin que la
collectivité territoriale puisse être
soutenue à hauteur de 2 millions d'euros
dans cette course contre la menthe qui
je le rappelle quand même vise à
préserver également un lien économique
sur le plus petit village de
monteritoire de 500 âmes et donc c'est
un vecteur
essentiel pour notre territoire et c'est
vraiment un appel du piège j'aimerais
vous entendre évidemment sur ce sujet
Quelle est la vie de la Commission
oui madame la Présidente donc le
président Tano
proposé un amendement qui vise à
soutenir la collectivité territoire de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon il l'a dit à
hauteur de 2 millions d'euros pour
protéger les espaces du littoral les
biens les habitants et les
infrastructures des communes en danger
en raison des aléas climatiques que nous
connaissons tous dans chacun de nos
territoires mais qui ont touché plus
particulièrement l'archipel à ce titre
et nous sommes l'important rappeler que
les communes archipel peuvent bénéficier
de la dottr pour financer une partie de
leurs investissements et néanmoins
regarde la surface financière il est
fort possible que ces aides ne suffisent
pas
par ailleurs Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
également signé un contrat de
convergence et de transformation pour un
montant 9,5 millions d'euros qui ont
permis entre autres de financer les
études et aménagement cela a été évoqué
le barrage de la vigie et pour la route
de l'ismes à Miquelon et pour la route
littorale de Saint-Pierre la
renégociation de ce contrat est prévue
en 2023 pour être l'occasion de prévoir
les crédits pour les travaux nécessaires
à la protection du littoral mais les
crédits seraient alors disponible qu'en
2024 c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
vie du gouvernement sur le sujet
du gouvernement
sujet je suis désolé monsieur le
ceinture qui n'est pas unique à Miquelon
on a le même pro le même souci grave à
OVA c'est pas un Drôme mais
l'archipeline va être coupée en deux
sujets du déménagement entre guillemets
du village lui-même le monter un petit
peu et puis il y a tout un tas d'îles
dans le Pacifique qui si la mer monte
d'un maître c'est fini voilà donc on a
un sujet global et c'est au nom de ce
sujet global que nous avons travaillé
avec le ministère de Monsieur Béchu pour
essayer d'avoir ce plan global
sur les sujets sur les terres les îles
les archipels en grand danger en grand
danger
le gouvernement m'a donc demandé en
liaison avec le secrétaire d'État de
Madame Couillard établir un document
clair sur outremer et changement
climatique à la fois ce que les
territoires amènent déjà à la lutte
contre le changement climatique avec
leur richesse maritime avec leur
richesse forestière quelle est la
contribution déjà à cet effort mondial
qui est fait et les outre-mer en font
beaucoup deuxième partie ce qui va pas
bien ce qui va pas bien c'est les
énergies
notamment dans l'archipel polynésien
mais on progresse avec 60 millions
d'euros qui ont été dégagés là-dessus on
progresse un peu partout le troisième
sujet c'est les territoires en danger
c'est les territoires en danger qui
feront l'objet j'en ai reparlé avec le
ministre déçu qui vont faire l'objet
d'un plan global là-dessus et sénateur
l'indiqué je précise qu'il y a aussi des
crédits qui sont disponibles sur le
décide
l'équivalent pour les départements de la
décile donc moi je s'il y a d'urgence on
les prendra sur Lesse au moins c'est
plus simple on sait qu'il décide et ça
va et direct mais créer un dépense
spéciale pour Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
pour ce sujet
il y a tellement d'autres territoires en
danger que je préfère un plan global en
vous assurant que si il y a besoin en
2023 si on avance pas assez vite c'est 2
millions d'euros seront disponibles je
vois que sur les FSE cette année faut
que je fasse des miracles pour le
dépenser donc
à l'appui avec ces arguments je souhaite
le retrait de cette demande de cet
amendement
la Commission elle-même avis que le
gouvernement
pas de Monsieur
899 madame jasmin
merci madame la Présidente alors c'est
une amendement alors je sais très bien
que la sécurité relève du domaine
régalien de l'État mais dans le contexte
actuel beaucoup de collectivités sont
confrontés à des problématiques liées à
la violence et à l'insécurité donc par
cet amendement je demande un fond de
coopération qui serait peut-être fléchés
à partir de crédit sécurité donc c'est
ça l'objet de mon de mon amendement et
je ne demande pas beaucoup en plus un
million 500 000 euros
c'est pas beaucoup parce que je sais que
c'est l'état mais les collectivités de
proximité sont confrontés régulièrement
et de plus en plus et c'est le cas à
Mayotte en Guy avec Saint-Laurent du
Maroni à proximité mais aussi sur les
autres territoires y compris maintenant
de plus en plus chez nous en Guadeloupe
quelle est la ville de la Commission
oui alors le fond de coopération
régionale qui est dotée d'un peu moins
d'1,5 millions d'euros par an bise
essentiellement à mettre en place
d'action de coopération économique vous
le savez social et culturel avec les
autres pays des régions ultramarines à
ce jour il n'a pas de compétences en
lien avec les problématiques
d'immigration de sécurité de défense il
faudrait donc modifier le CGT article
r443-24 et suivant pour étendre ses
compétences à ces thématiques mais en
l'absence d'une telle évolution et nous
paraît pas possible d'ouvrir les crédits
à cette fin donc c'est un avis
défavorable
et vous restez d'ailleurs pour la maman
de 902 madame jasmin
est un amendement qui concerne une
spécifique pour l'aide à la citerne je
dirais parce qu'il y a de vrais
problèmes de vrais sujets concernant la
distribution de l'eau et lorsqu'il s'est
agit d'examiner le texte concernant la
création de syndicats uniques de l'eau à
l'époque j'avais alerté sur les limites
de l'exercice et il fallait qu'il y ait
des fonds et malheureusement mais
c'était une coquille vit dans le roi ou
l'État a repris la main mais à cause de
ces problèmes d'eau il y a beaucoup
d'écoles qui ferment chaque fois qu'il y
a pas d'eau pour les raisons d'hygiène
et je vous souhaite vraiment qu'il y ait
un accompagnement pour permettre aux
enfants d'aller régulièrement à l'école
quand il s'agit de période où il y a des
coupures d'eau ce n'est pas normal c'est
intenable et polygiène pour la sécurité
ce serait intéressant que cet amendement
puisse être adopté merci
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
de cet enjeu majeur le plan haut adopté
en 2016 pour une durée de 10 ans a déjà
permis d'engager 126 millions d'euros de
eux et de consommer au 31 juillet 2022
72,5 millions d'euros de CP à partir des
crédits de la mission outre-mer sur ce
montant 58 millions en aeux et 39
millions en CP viennent du FUI le delta
provenant
des contrats
même si ces regrettable les crédits du
FEI sont sous consommer ces dernières
années ainsi les crédits existent et
nous avons fait des recommandations pour
qu'il soit pleinement consommés soyez
assurés que nous y serons insensifs et
quand le Fuji sera intégralement
consommé manuellement nous pourrons
demander légitimement une augmentation
des crédits ouverts à ce titre notamment
pour des investissements liés à l'accès
à l'eau potable
inquiété dans cet amendement mais je
l'avais vu en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique c'est l'attitude de
l'éducation nationale qui n'autorise pas
des citernes dans les écoles
j'y travaille l'administration française
est ainsi faite c'est lourd à travailler
sur un sujet pourtant simple tout le
monde y a droit sauf dans les écoles
c'est comme ça
mais on a aussi sur l'eau je vais pas
revenir sur Mayotte sur la Guadeloupe
le sujet de l'assainissement la vertu de
cette amendement si je peux me permettre
c'est outre l'éducation nationale c'est
sur l'assainissement mais ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure sur un autre sujet
je pense qu'on est très concentré sur
l'eau potable et pas assez sur
l'assainissement donc à la fin on va
voir des ennuis ça c'est clair
mais j'ai pas le moyen de le faire et
donc parce que j'ai l'amendement je
dirais c'était un amendement d'appel et
vous avez raison mais c'est pas un
amendement financier donc oui c'est bien
mais j'y mettrai pas l'argent en la par
ailleurs défavorable madame jasm
maintenu je mets aux voix qui est pour
double vie défavorable qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
928 madame
la prostitante je reprends ici un
amendement que les membres du groupe GDR
à l'Assemblée nationale au sein duquel
siège un certain nombre d'élus
ultramarin donc les membres de ce groupe
aurait bien voulu débattre à l'Assemblée
nationale et on sait les raisons pour
lesquelles ça n'a pu se faire donc il
s'agit de demander un meilleur
investissement de l'État au sein des
départements d'outre-mer et notamment en
Polynésie le fond intercommunal de
péréquation a diminué de ce fait c'est
le service de public de l'eau qui est
remis en cause les communes n'ont pas
les moyens nécessaires d'assurer la
maintenance des réseaux d'adduction
d'eau qui est une compétence communale
si les travaux ne peuvent avoir lieu ce
sont des dégâts environnementaux donc
qui vont entrer en jeu et en effet le
manque d'entretien des réseaux
d'adduction d'eau entraîne vous le savez
sans doute d'énormes fuites l'eau je le
rappelle est un bien commun essentiel
les conséquences du réchauffement qui
compte ce bien de plus en plus rare le
perdre parce que l'État ne donnerait pas
les moyens nécessaires à ça maintenant
voulait pas monsieur le ministre mais
d'une
irresponsabilité sans nom donc il faut
donner les moyens à la Polynésie et aux
collectivités d'outre-mer de protéger ce
bien essentiel et de le rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre je vous
remercie
oui alors donner à la vie de la
commission mais j'ai aussi élu de
Polynésie française donc je connais
quand même un peu le sujet je voudrais
être que Madame tétouanoui ne soit pas
là qu'elle n'est pas été là aussi tout à
l'heure pour l'autre avant moment parce
que ce qui est un peu gênant c'est qu'il
y a des discussions qui sont ouvertes il
y a des négociations en cours et dans
l'autre abandon par exemple on
mélangeait la question du remboursement
des frais engagés par la CPS pour la
dette nucléaire l'arrêt des essais
nucléaires la mise en place d'une taxe
et d'une TV associée à qui n'est pas une
TVA et on vient appeler l'État à venir
combler un déficit qui est à accrue par
des décisions prises localement et on ne
veut pas aller au bout et on vote un
amendement à l'emporte-pièce finalement
pour mettre un coup d'arrêt à ces
discussions qui sont des discussions
basées sur la conférence et c'est un peu
le même sujet qui est là pardonnez-moi
de réagir aussi fortement parce que il y
a bien un sujet effectivement de
quote-part de financement de l'État du
FIP qui organise la péréquation entre
les communes polynésiennes mais qui est
aujourd'hui dans l'application de la loi
organique et du statut qui a été donné à
la Polynésie française donc c'est un
sujet
nous avons souhaité ouvrir avec Madame
cailleux en charge des collectivités
territoriales et pas avec le soutien
mais bien entendu j'espère bienveillant
du ministère de l'Outre-mer mais nous ne
sommes pas sur la mission outre-mer dans
le cas de ce sujet particulier et qui ne
peut pas se restreindre dans la question
de l'eau en Polynésie qui est un vrai
sujet donc pour toutes ces raisons nous
vous demandons un retrait de cette
amendement les fondements de votre
intervention sont certainement
justifiées bien entendu par contre nous
ne sommes pas je pense sur la bonne
mission merci
avis du gouvernement
je veux dire que le gouvernement ne se
désintéresse pas de la Polynésie mais il
veut le faire en plein accord avec le
gouvernement polynésien on a évoqué sur
les 42 millions tout à l'heure je
voudrais évoquer aussi les 60 millions
de transformations de la PPE si j'allais
dire du mix énergétique sur l'ensemble
des îles polynésiennes c'est un sujet
qu'on a travaillé ensemble depuis un an
avec le gouvernement polynésien et ça
vient d'aboutir les 60 millions vont
peut-être délégués donc je soutiens
effectivement ce qu'a dit c'est un
terroriste c'est la Polynésie c'est pas
la Lozère donc on essaye de travailler
ensemble et de répondre à ces attentes
dans le cadre des lois qui régissent les
rapports de l'État central avec la
Polynésie voilà donc c'est un
avis confort parce qu'a dit le chanteur
aux frites c'est donc un avis
défavorable
ment de parler de l'environnement de
plus en plus et de maîtriser à la fois
l'énergie et tout ce qui s'en suit il y
a de plus en plus une volonté des
établissements d'un froid et des
propositions aussi de tous ceux qui
construisent d'avoir des établissements
HQE Haute Qualité Environnementale avec
la récupération de l'eau de pluie
monsieur le ministre pour les toilettes
pour se laver les mains donc il faudrait
un moment donné que nous soyons
cohérentes dans notre démarche
collective il y a déjà en Guadeloupe des
établissements HQE et on récupère je
prends il y a des exemples au lieu d'en
oublier donc il faudrait justement qu'il
y a cette possibilité là aussi parce que
vous affichez des motivations et des
politiques en faveur de l'environnement
la maîtrise l'énergie de tout ce qu'il y
a et de l'eau également concernant
également vous avez parlé de l'eau et de
l'assainissement l'assainissement
monsieur le ministre les services de
l'État sont si coupables de la situation
dans laquelle et nous sommes parce que
il y avait des délégations de services
publics qui ont été payées le service de
la légalité n'a pas fait son job le
service à l'égalité voilà c'est ça le
problème moi je suis jeune et lui un peu
bon je n'ai pas tout dit mais vous le
savez très bien et moi je ne manquerai
pas pour le dire mais si je suis de la
légalité faisait correctement son
travail c'est le service fait et bien on
ne serait pas dans cette dans cette
situation là merci
madame billon bien sûr monsieur du
ministre
merci Madame la merci madame la
Présidente je j'avais pas prévu
d'intervenir mais j'ai souhaité
réintervenir parce que j'ai entendu le
rapporteur qui comme tout à l'heure
lorsque la sénatrice cancone c'est un
petit peu fâché lorsqu'on parlait de ses
événements il a été question de d'un
amendement à l'emporte-pièce concernant
l'amendement que j'ai défendu de ma
collègue Lana tétouani alors moi ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que je n'ai pas
eu du tout l'impression de défendre un
amendement à l'emporte-pièce et je ne
l'aurais pas défendu avec toute cette
toute cette vigueur si ça avait été le
cas
ce type de commentaire n'a rien à faire
dans notre hémicycle ni en porte-pièce
ni effet de manche on peut pas remettre
en question l'engagement de la sénatrice
du groupe Union centriste la note et
touani ça fait presque 8 ans que nous
sommes ensemble sur ces bancs et dans
notre groupe
et je connais l'amour de son territoire
de votre territoire monsieur le
rapporteur et donc bien entendu
l'amendement a été défendu pour toutes
ces raisons et j'aurais souhaité que on
se dispense de ce commentaire merci
monsieur le ministre
l'environnement relève de la Polynésie
française de par la Constitution c'est
bien si on dit respecte la Constitution
les lois organiques donc voilà donc le
code de l'environnement et de relève de
la poésie ceci dit tout à l'heure c'est
plus c'est peut-être vous un instinct
qui disait l'État est coupable
le premier coupable c'est celui qui
commet l'illégalité
d'accord non mais quand tu veux un truc
qui légal il y a un grand coupable et un
petit coupable je préfère simplement le
petit coupable mais je reconnais cette
petite culpabilité
monsieur le rapporteur
madame billon je suis aussi élu de
Polynésie française vous savez je suis
tout aussi légitime que Madame
tétouanoui pour parler de mon territoire
comme vous l'êtes pour parler de votre
territoire bien entendu
ce qui est qualifié dans porte nous
sommes les élus de la République
nous sommes des élus de la République
madame mais effectivement ce qui était à
l'emporte-pièce ça n'est pas l'action
madame tétonoui c'est la construction de
cet amendement qui vient mélanger les
sujets qui sont que le remboursement des
frais engagés par la CPS pendant les
essais nucléaires et si vous estimez que
les 42 millions d'euros que vous avez
obtenus par ce vote vont régler
effectivement ce sujet majeur pour la
Polynésie française vous faites une
erreur et permettez-moi de vous le dire
en tant qu'élu de Polynésie française et
de la République madame
non non le ministre a déjà parlé on va
donc mettre au voile 928 avec double
avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
nous allons maintenant procéder au vote
des crédits de la mission outre-mer je
vous rappelle que la commission des
finances est favorable à l'adoption qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés je me vois l'article 44 quaters
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés le 44 quinquièces qui
est pour qui est contre même vote sont
adoptés après l'article à l'article 44
succès un amendement des rapporteurs
celui que vous voulez
je prends
et de repousser de 3 mois la date limite
de dépôt du rapport de Vendée au
gouvernement sur les crédits budgétaires
dédiés à l'aide aux frettes au sein de
la mission outre-mer en effet pour qu'un
rapport soit utile il faut qu'il soit
suffisamment complet et instruit dans de
bonnes conditions dans ce contexte des
lettres trois mois proposé par les cours
et il est proposé de le porter à 6 mois
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cet amendement de la commission qui